kriegsziele aber wir sind in der
haushaltswoche daher wird es sicherlich
auch um die 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr gehen um steigende inflation
um steigende schulden noch hat die
debatte nicht begonnen natürlich
schalten wir sofort ins plenum wir sehen
dass der kanzler bereits da ist also
sobald es losgeht schalten wir natürlich
um aber vorher spreche ich jetzt mit
meiner kollegin andrea maurer aus
unserem hauptstadtstudio die debatte vor
ort im bundestag verfolgen wird andrea
was ist denn da heute zu erwarten
was wir hören ist dass oppositionsführer
friedrich merz hier heute vor allem auf
attacke setzen wird er wird diese
debatte jahr eröffnen und er wird da
wohl den ton setzen was friedrich merz
dem kanzler in den letzten tagen
vermehrt vorgeworfen hat ist dass ein
abwägen vor allem ängstlichkeit sei und
fehlende strategie und obwohl also ampel
und union sich diese woche auf das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
geeinigt haben wird friedrich merz heute
versuchen sich weiter als gegenspieler
des kanzlers in position zu bringen was
sicher heute auch thema sein wird ist
das was hier vor fast genau einem monat
durchs parlament gegangen ist auch auf
einigung von union und ampel hin nämlich
die lieferung schwerer waffen da gibt es
ja durchaus kritik am kanzler die bilanz
ist nicht besonders glanzvoll es hat
verzögerungen gegeben widersprüchliche
erklärungen und da wird erwartet dass
der kanzler heute vielleicht sogar auf
diese kritik reagiert er verspreche
vielfalt liefere wenig und vielleicht
sogar die lieferung neuer waffen
ankündigt es gibt ja neben dem krieg
auch im inland drängende probleme wie
die ständig steigende inflation die
steigenden belastungen für die bürger
wird es nicht zeit auch dazu konkrete
konzepte vorzulegen am wochenende
präsentierte hubertus heil ja seine
pläne für ein klima geld aber das
scheint ja noch nicht durch zu sein
ja also preissteigerungen inflation die
die die erhöhten lebensmittelpreise das
alles wird hier heute sicher im
parlament auch thema sein das was heute
in kraft tritt da ist schon klar also
neun euro ticket und tanz tank rabatt
diese entlastung werden nicht reichen
und während der finanzen dennoch darüber
tüftelt wie eben diese
milliardenschweren entlastungs paket das
sondervermögen neuverschuldung wie das
alles finanziert werden soll da bringt
der arbeitsminister eben das soziale
klima geld ins spiel also für einkommen
bis zu 4000 euro brutto die höhe ist
unklar die kosten sind auch noch offen
arbeitsminister heil spricht von einen
zweistelligen milliarden betrag und da
deutet sich eben ein neuer streit in der
koalition an während beim sondervermögen
eben vor allem bei den linken in grüne
und spd ist eben kritik gab und zögern
da es jetzt hier bei einem sozialen
klima geld und weiteren entlastung vor
allem die fdp auf der bremse ganz
herzlichen dank andrea ich sehe der
oppositionsführer friedrich merz ist am
rednerpult wir hören jetzt mal rein
kolleginnen und kollegen am vergangenen
sonntagabend
konnten wir uns mit den
koalitionsfraktionen auf die
einzelheiten einer grundgesetzänderung
zur errichtung eines sondervermögens
verständigen mit dem die ausrüstung und
die ausrüstung der bundeswehr
zusätzlich mit 100 milliarden euro
ausgestattet werden dieser sonntag war
und ist zuallererst ein guter tag für
die bündnisse und verteidigungsfähigkeit
unseres landes unter ist ein guter tag
für die bundeswehr
ich will an dieser stelle herzlich dank
sagen an diejenigen die auf unserer
seite der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
die gespräche mit den
koalitionsfraktionen geführt haben
unsere kollegen alexander dobrindt
mathias middelberg zur wadephul und
florian hahn herzlichen dank dafür dass
sie die verhandlungen zielorientiert und
konstruktiv in unser aller namen geführt
haben
ebenfalls ein dank sagen an die
koalitionsfraktionen
dass sie bereit waren unseren wünschen
vollumfänglich zu folgen was die
ausgestaltung dieses sondervermögen
naja also wenn sie sie sind unseren
wünschen vollumfänglich nachgekommen und
ich will das noch mal kurze referieren
die 100 milliarden werden nur für die
bundeswehr zur verfügung gestellt es
wird einen wirtschaftsplan geben in dem
alle vorhaben aufgelistet werden die
bundeswehr wird erstmalig in ihrer
geschichte einen
finanzierungsgesetz bekommen indem
klargestellt wird dass deutschland auch
nach der erschöpfung dieser 100
milliarden euro alle verpflichtungen
gegenüber der nato auch in zukunft
einhalten wird und das können auch mehr
als zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandproduktes sein meine damen
und herren und das ist ein guter
vorschlag gewesen
gar nicht erst von ihm vorgetragen wurde
es wird darüber hinaus bis zur
sommerpause und der bundeskanzler da
sehen wir sie in der pflicht das
wirklich auch einzuhalten was ihre
verhandlungsführer zugesagt haben einen
vorschlag zur reform des
beschaffungswesens geben den sehen wir
als notwendig und als dringlich an es
wird schließlich eine beteiligung des
haushaltsausschusses mit einem
unterausschuss geben an der einzelnen
finanzierung und es wird abschließend
der bundesfinanzminister einen
tilgungsplan geben den sie ebenfalls
zugesagt
besser hätten wir es nicht zu einem
abschluss gemeinsam bringen können
herzlichen dank nochmal auch an ihre
adresse weinberg
da hätten wir uns gewünscht dass auch im
hinblick auf die unmittelbare
herausforderung
der wir in diesen tagen und wochen
gestellt sind nämlich der eindämmung des
krieges in der ukraine
ähnlich klare und eindeutige politische
entscheidungen in deutschland
getroffen worden wären werden zu allen
gewünscht meine damen und herren dass
die bundesregierung dem wunsch und dem
auftrag des deutschen bundestages
nachgekommen wäre den wir wenn auch herr
bundeskanzler in ihrer abwesenheit am 28
april ebenfalls in großer
übereinstimmung wie im deutschen
bundestag in einem entschließungsantrag
formuliert haben wir haben zur
erinnerung unter anderem beschlossen
neben der humanitären und finanziellen
hilfe der ukraine auch schwere waffen zu
liefern damit dieses land sich gegen die
russische aggression ausreichend und
erfolgreich verteidigen kann
so haben sie gemeinsam sie
muss ich feststellen mehr als einen
monat nach dieser gemeinsamen
entschließung im deutschen bundestag
sind der ukraine bis zum heutigen tag
die zugesagten waffen nicht geliefert
worden mehr als einem monat statt dessen
werden von mitgliedern ihrer
bundesregierung der bundeskanzler und
aus ihrer partei heraus ständig
irgendwelche behauptungen aufgestellt
die schlicht und einfach falsch sind so
wird von einer parlamentarischen
staatssekretärin aus dem
bundesverteidigungsministerium behauptet
es gebe da eine nato vereinbarung dass
es keine schweren waffen
gelte für die ukraine ihre
parteivorsitzende bundeskanzler sagt
auch andere länder würden keine schweren
waffen liefern sei zwar keine formale
vereinbarung aber so eine art informelle
vereinbarung dass diese waffen nicht
geliefert und sie herr bundeskanzler
reden in letzter zeit etwas mehr als
sonst aber sie sagen unverändert nichts
was ist eine ihrer meinung zu dem was
dieser koalition
er hat man sich um unter den staats und
regierungschefs den abgeordneten in der
europäischen union dann kann ich
feststellen über die haltung der
bundesregierung gibt es mittlerweile nur
noch verstimmungen vorsichtig formuliert
es gibt enttäuschungen über die unklare
rolle deutschlands und es gibt richtig
verärgerung über sie und ihre regierung
und nicht nur während die opposition
sondern abgeordnete aus ihren reihen
herr bundeskanzler machen ihrem ärger
und ihrem unmut über das was hier in den
letzten tagen und wochen geschieht immer
lauter luft bis hin zu der wortmeldung
einer europaabgeordneten der kollegin
viola von cramon von den grünen die in
der letzten woche gesagt hat sie
brüsteten sich damit was man bereits für
die ukraine schon alles geleistet habe
sie würden dabei auf absprachen
verweisen mit vermeintlichen partnern
die es überhaupt nicht gebe ohne die
hilfe der usa sei die ukraine längst von
russland überrollt worden
abschließendes zitat für deutschland
bleibt jetzt nur noch verachtung übrig
ja das ist nicht aus unseren reihen
bundeskanzler das kommt aus ihren reihen
aus den reihen ihrer kirche
in dieser woche titelte die faz
chance ruiniert das ansehen der
deutschen politik
wörtliches zitat im text olaf scholz hat
immer wieder auf seinen amtseid
hingewiesen schaden vom deutschen volk
abzuwenden
den schaden den er gerade in nicht
abwendet liegt im ansehensverlust der
deutschen politik
reflektion und vorsicht so schreibt
einer der herausgeber der faz
reflexion um vorsicht geld nicht ohne
grund als tugenden sie als fassade für
zaudern zu verwenden ist unredlich
und wirklich so eine auszeichnung durch
eine große deutsche tageszeitung muss
man sich erstmal verdienen
unredlich steht als synonym für
böswillig verschweigen
unaufrichtig haben ungern wer meine
damen und herren was verschweigen sie
uns eigentlich herr bundeskanzler
sie telefonieren 80 minuten mit dem
hamburg mit dem russischen
staatspräsidenten
und morgen kommt der
parlamentspräsident der ukraine nach
deutschland nach berlin und sie
verweigern ihm bis zu dieser minute
einen gesprächstermin
herr bundeskanzler doch was ist da
eigentlich los in ihrer regierung ich
kann begrenzt verstehen dass sie nicht
nach kiew reisen wollen aber wenn der
parlamentspräsident der zweithöchste
repräsentant der ukraine morgen in
berlin ist warum geben sie dem
parlamentspräsidenten der ukraine keinen
gesprächstermin was die stelle
und was heißt das
was heißt das wenn sie sagen russland
darf diesen krieg nicht gewinnen
was heißt das wenn sie sagen die ukraine
muss fortbestehen warum sagen sie nicht
einfach und ganz klar die ukraine muss
diesen krieg gewinnen
[Applaus]
muss und warum sagen sie es nicht ganz
klar russland muss zumindest hinter die
kontakt linie vom 24 februar 2022
zurückgedrängt werden
rückfahrt wird ihr geschlecht auf der
welt und in europa ist sagen es ist auch
nicht meine oder unsere frage allein
gibt es da mittlerweile eine zweite
agenda warum widerspricht aus ihren
reihen der spd niemand ihrem
amtsvorgänger im amt des bürgermeisters
der freien und hansestadt hamburg klaus
von dohnanyi der hier in diesen tagen
durch berlin von einer talkshow in die
andere geht russland in schutz nimmt
putin verteidigt und fast ausschließlich
den vereinigten staaten von amerika die
schuld an diesem krieg zuweist herr
bundeskanzler was machen sie da und
warum stellen sie das nicht klar was sie
für eine meinung zu diesem thema
wir haben am 27 februar von dieser
stelle aus eine vielbeachtete
regierungserklärung abgegeben sie haben
hier im deutschen bundestag sehr viel
zustimmung bekommen
stehenden applaus auch von meiner
fraktion
ja das haben wir wohl zur kenntnis
genommen haben meine damen und herren
aber sie bleiben doch hinter den selbst
gestellten ansprüchen dieses 27 februar
mittlerweile tag für tag immer weiter
zurück sie haben an diesem tag klartext
gesprochen
sie haben an diesem tag gesagt die sind
die lage sehen seitdem verdampft und
verdunstet das alles was sie da gesagt
haben im unklaren im ungefähren und es
wird keine konkrete entscheidung
getroffen und hier begründet die an
dieses niveau und in diesem level
anschließen sie am 27 februar 2022 hier
selbst gesetzt hat
sich mit einem zweiten aspekt hinzu
fügen wir sind ja nicht allein auf
dieser welt aber warum gibt es
eigentlich warum gibt es eigentlich von
ihrer regierung der bundeskanzler auch
von ihnen persönlich keine einzige
europäische initiative zum beispiel
zusammen mit dem französischen
staatspräsidenten wie man in einer
solchen historischen situation jetzt
europa voran bringt und mit anderen
mitgliedstaaten zusammen auch in der
europäischen politik klar zeigt in
welche richtung jetzt europa entwickelt
werden soll und welche chancen europa
auch in diesem konflikt sieht für die
eigene bessere integration in der außen-
sicherheits- und verteidigungspolitik
ich würde es mal so sagen haben sie
eigentlich außer der
formalen rhetorik irgendeinen vorschlag
wie sich europa in dieser historischen
phase des umbruchs aufstellen und
dauerhaft auch verteidigen kann gibt es
irgend ein vorschlag aus ihrer regierung
wenn sie wenigstens teile des geld ist
dass wir jetzt in diesem sondervermögen
bereitstellen wollen in eine europäische
sicherheitsarchitektur ein die es uns
erlaubt schritt für schritt hin zu einer
europäischen außen- sicherheits- und
verteidigungspolitik zu kommen und in
diesem zusammenhang wie wird eigentlich
die bundesregierung wie werden sie herr
bundeskanzler votieren wenn in wenigen
tagen der neuesten nächste europäische
rat stattfindet und auf der tagesordnung
steht die frage ob der ukraine moldau
und ob den westbalkanstaaten der
beitritt status der kandidatenstatus in
die europäische union gegeben wird herr
bundeskanzler das können sie doch nicht
der eu kommission überlassen das
irgendwie formal vorzubereiten das ist
doch eine zutiefst politische
entscheidung in der aufführung erwartet
in der klarheit erwartet
natürlich davon wählen sie es offen
lassen wenn die größte nation der
europäischen union in dieser frage
unklar bleibt und keine klare antwort
gibt dann bleibt es in ganz europa
unklar und dann wird es in ganz europa
keine antwort geben also bitte sagen sie
was sie von dieser frage halten und wie
sie das sehen die westbalkanstaaten
moldau und die ukraine sollen sie den
kandidaten status bekommen oder nicht
oder aber setzen sie das wort mit ihrer
politik was sie als finanzminister schon
in den letzten jahren ihrer regierung
getan haben nämlich praktisch jedes geld
jedes problem einfach nur mit neuem geld
zuzuschütten und ansonsten politischen
entscheidungen aus dem wege zu gehen
doch auch in dem zusammenhang mit dem
bundeshaushalt 2022 stellen sind ihnen
eigentlich die risiken bewusst mit denen
sie diesen bundeshaushalt in dieser
woche hier verabschieden wollen und zwar
auch ganz unabhängig von den neuen
schulden die jetzt mit diesem
sondervermögen gemacht werden es könnte
doch sein der bundeskanzler dass sie
schon in wenigen wochen 60 milliarden
euro für den klima- und energiefonds gar
nicht zur verfügung haben weil ihnen das
bundesverfassungsgericht nicht erlaubt
diese mittel aus dem chor ohne hilfen
aus dem chor ohne hilfen zweck zu
für die entscheidungen ihrer regierung
die eigentlich aus dem normalen haushalt
finanziert werden müssten
das könnte sagen es könnte sein dass sie
jahr für jahr zehn milliarden euro
zurückzahlen müssen an diejenigen die
einkommensteuer und körperschaftsteuer
zahlen weil es an ihnen gescheitert ist
in solidaritätszuschlag in der letzten
wahlperiode vollständig abzuschaffen das
ist ein jährliches ließen
[Applaus]
die übrigens in den zusammen haben wenn
sie damals nicht aus ideologischen
gründen sich geweigert hätten den soli
ganz abzuschaffen sie hätten heute mit
diesem instrument das sie selbst
diskreditiert haben sie hätten heute mit
diesem instrument ein instrument zur
verfügung mit dem wir wahrscheinlich die
neuen schulden für das sondervermögen
bundeswehr gar nicht hätten aufnehmen
müssen sie hätten uns nämlich den
vorschlag machen können der
bundeskanzler dass wir einen solchen
solidaritäts zuschlag erheben auf die
einkommensteuer und auch die
körperschaftssteuer für die bundeswehr
dann wäre das vom heutigen generationen
bezahlt worden was eigentlich aufgabe
der heutigen generation ist und nicht
die jungen fraktion in einigen jahren
und jahrzehnten mühsam
böse abzahlen und in dem zusammenhang
was sagen sie eigentlich der jungen
generation das sagen ja dass dabei um
gruber ihn auf pump das kann ich gut
verstehen meine damen und herren bei
[Musik]
dem mord sowie glänzen ihre augen nicht
das hätten sie gerne aber sie können
nicht einführen weil sie dieses
instrument einfach mutwillig zerstört
was sagen sie eigentlich der
bundeskanzler der jungen generation dass
sie es erneut versäumt auch mit diesem
bundeshaushalt eine reform der 1
was sagen sie eigentlich der jungen
generation
[Musik]
was sagen sie eigentlich der jungen
generation dass sie es erneut versäumt
eine reform der rentenversicherung
vorzulegen die einerseits den
bundeszuschuss begrenzt und andererseits
der jungen generation eine sichere
altersversorgung ermöglicht auch hier
eine zahl wie
stress gibt ich kann das ich kann das
gut verstehen das ist nicht nur da
sondern auch da auf der regierungsbank
gehörige unruhe gibt sie müssen sie
müssen sie müssen mehr als 100
milliarden euro pro jahr an zuschuss in
die rentenversicherung zahlen es gibt
bis heute kein vorschlag aus ihrer
koalition diese rentenversicherung zu
reformieren der letzte reformvorschlag
ist an ihnen gescheitert und an ihnen
der bundeskanzler in der letzten
koalition
wir hätten hier längst eine reform
machen müssen sie ist an ihnen
gescheitert sie haben ihre zustimmung
verweigert um gegen reformvorschlag der
gemacht worden ist und so bleibt heute
festzustellen das wort zeitenwende dass
sie am 27 februar
2022 geprägt und verwendet haben dieses
vor ort zeitenwende bleibt außer neuen
schulden für dieses sondervermögen mehr
oder weniger beziehungslos im raum
stehen es gibt nichts was sie außer
neuen schulden mit diesem wort zeigten
verwende zeitenwende ernsthaft verbinden
alles
[Musik]
so schön bleiben wie sie es in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag der mittlerweile nur
noch ins archiv gehört wie sie in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag verabredet haben im
gegenteil aus ihren reihen kommen fast
im wochenrhythmus neue vorschläge wie
man zusätzliches geld ausgibt der
jüngste vorschlag ihres sozialministers
ein soziales klima geld für einkommen
bis 8000 euro im monat
schauen sie sich mal die reihen dieser
koalition kann bei diesem wort soziales
klima geht welche reaktionen dass hier
im haus wird das sind 20
das ist so ganz die ganze zeit unterwegs
partei noch ein bisschen aber ansonsten
viel mehr für dieses thema sie machen
solche vorschläge hier und ohne jede
finanzierung einfach zusätzliche neue
schulden das ist die botschaft dieser
regierung und ist ganz nah ich möchte in
einen vorschlag machen zum abschluss
meiner rede sie haben vermutlich eine
vorformulierte ausformulierte rede des
bundeskanzleramtes mitgebracht heute
morgen legen sie doch mal auf die seite
und beantworten sie bitte wenn es eben
mögliches drei sehr konkrete fragen die
erste frage ist welche waffen liefert
die bundesrepublik deutschland wirklich
an die ukraine welche waffen wollen sie
liefern was ist ihre präzise antwort auf
diese frage zweitens
zweiter
der bundeskanzler wie werden sie
europäischen rat abstimmen wenn die
frage beantwortet werden muss gibt es
für die ukraine und andere staaten den
beitritt status den kandidatenstatus in
die europäische union und dritte frage
auch die wirtsleute morgen abweichend
vom vorgetragenen vorgelesenen
redemanuskript ihr zu beantworten welche
vorschläge machen sie zur reform der
deutschen rentenversicherung damit die
junge generation in diesem land eine
perspektive auch andere sicher ein
altersversorgung ich finde jeder sollte
anspruch darauf in einer debatte über
den etat des bundeskanzlers diese fragen
beantwortet
das war cdu chef friedrich merz er lobte
die einigung beim sondervermögen klar
die union hat sich hier schon in vielen
punkten durchgesetzt aber dann gab es
heftige kritik an bundeskanzler olaf
scholz rede mehr als sonst sage aber
nichts sein zaudern sei unredlich so
gebe es keine vorschläge zum beispiel
für europa für eine reform der renten
nächster redner ist nun der
bundeskanzler der die chance hat diese
vorwürfe zu entkräften
als nächstes spricht nun für die
bundesregierung der bundeskanzler olaf
scholz
fährt er märz sie haben sich mit dem
text den sie sich vorbereitet haben wir
ein manuskript ja sehr viel mühe gegeben
allerdings muss man ausdrücklich sagen
das was sie hier vorgetragen hat sind
lauter fragen sie sind hier durch die
sache durch die tänze und haben nichts
konkretes gesagt moabit wäre wirklich
sehr vernünftig gewesen
wenn sie nicht mit durchkommen immer nur
fragen zu stellen und sich niemals in
irgendeiner frage sinnvoll zu
positionieren und wenn sie es dann
machen dann wird's peinlich also 7
sie kritisieren her dass ich mit dem
russischen präsidenten telefoniert
und sie kritisieren hier dass ich mit
dem russischen präsidenten
telefonieren sie montieren das dann
sagen sie ich soll was gemeinsam mit dem
französischen präsident machen und
während sie in ihrer rede dass inseriert
haben haben sie völlig übersehen das
letzte telefongespräch war ein
gemeinsames mit dem französischen
präsidenten übrigens eine europäische
aktion dieser beiden länder die eine
wichtige rolle für die zukunft europas
spielt
und ganz anders als sie das hier
herstellen sind die anderen länder
europas überwiegend sehr sehr froh
darüber dass wir genau das machen und
freuen sich darüber dass wir mit in
unsere erkenntnisse austauschen dass wir
darüber reden was gemeinsam vorzutragen
ist und was wir tun wollen naja dann
hatten sie ja noch einen konkreten
vorschlag den muss man sich ja doch noch
mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen ihr
vorschlag den sie heute hier im
deutschen bundestag gemacht haben ist
dass wir die steuern für fast alle
bürger über ein soli erhöhen sollen um
die bessere ausrüstung der bundeswehr zu
bezahlen was für ein merkwürdiger
einfallen
einen ganzen bundestagswahlkampf haben
sie damit geführt zu sagen dass der soli
auch für die leute die 200 300 400
tausend euro im jahr verdienen weg muss
um dann jetzt vorzuschlagen dass leute
die 70.000 60.000 euro verdient den soli
jetzt aber zahlen sollen damit das jetzt
hier gemacht werden können das ist keine
gute idee
und werde er das fragen beantworten oder
sie sind alle längst beantwortet bei den
gelegenheiten dazu da waren aber ich
will ausdrücklich dazu sagen eins ist
schon ganz ganz zentral wenn man über
das redet was wir reden auch wenn es um
die verbesserung unserer
verteidigungsanstrengungen geht dann
muss man als oppositionsführer der von
der cdu csu kommt schon sagen die
verteidigungsministerien und minister
der letzten jahre waren in der cdu und
der csu die kanzlerin bei der cdu und
darüber hätten sie auch nicht links ein
wort verlieren
die schlechte zeit für die bundeswehr
hat begonnen als ein presse china viel
kommunizieren da selten sich in seinem
amt aufhalten
bundesverteidigungsminister guttenberg
entschieden hat alles mögliche anders zu
machen ordentlich einzusparen die
wehrpflicht abzuschaffen und darunter
leiden wir noch heute dass all das geld
damals zusammen gesprächen brauchen
manchmal ist sacharbeit wirklich eine
nützliche sache ernst
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die preise für benzin und diesel für
lebensmittel und fürs heizen steigen
rasant und millionen bürgerinnen und
bürger fragen sich jeden tag komme ich
ihn mit meinem geld reicht es noch am
monatsende
das sind sehr sehr sehr gravierende
fragen fragen auf die es in der tat eine
klare antwort braucht die
bundesregierung hat umfangreiche
entlastung von bürgern und bürger und
unternehmen auf den weg gebracht in der
summe reden wir über mehr als 30
milliarden euro
und diese entlastungen kommen jetzt an
in den nächsten tagen und wochen
rückwirkend ab januar wird die
pendlerpauschale erhöht um die hohen
spritpreise etwas auszugleichen am
ersten juli werden die stromrechnung
günstiger weil wir die eeg-umlage
streichen eine vierköpfige familie spart
zu mehrere hundert euro im jahr und ab
juli bekommen bürgerinnen und bürger mit
kleinen einkommen wohngeld
empfängerinnen und studierende mit bafög
ein zuschuss zu den heizkosten
familien werden gezielt entlastet durch
den kinderbonus von armut betroffene
kinder und jugendliche erhalten einen
sofort zuschlag und zwar monatlich jeder
beschäftigte erhält ab september zum
ausgleich für die gestiegenen
energiekosten einmalig 300 euro
ausgezahlt und schon heute treten zwei
maßnahmen kraft über die wohl am meisten
geredet worden ist in deutschland in den
vergangenen wochen die steuersenkung auf
benzin und diesel und das neun euro
ticket im öpnv
hier lasten damit diejenigen die nicht
aufs auto verzichten können und all
diejenigen die täglich bus und bahn
nutzen und vielleicht gewinnen wir auch
die eine oder andere in den anderen
dafür künftig etwas häufiger die
öffentlichen verkehrsmittel zu nutzen
jedenfalls ist der ansturm auf das neue
euro ticket ganz massiv und es zeigt die
maßnahmen wirken sie kommen direkt bei
den bürgern und bürgern an und das hat
diese bundesregierung und die
regierungsmehrheit im bundestag auf den
richter
weil die öffentlichkeit
ihre eigenen themen hat diskutieren die
scheiben der öffentlichkeit ist es so
dass das vielleicht noch nicht so
präsent geworden ist aber wenn das geld
denn jetzt gezahlt wird dann hoffe ich
wird den bürgern und bürgern die diese
hilfe wirklich dringend brauchen auch
sichtbar es kommt und das haben wir
gemacht übrigens profitieren auch die
renten und rentner von den entlastungs
paketen bei der stromrechnung vom tank
rabatt und dem neuen euro ticket und zum
ersten juli steigen die renten so stark
wie seit jahrzehnten nicht um 6,1
prozent 12 prozent im osten und über
5,35 im westen für drei millionen
rentnern rentner haben wir höhere
erwerbsminderungsrenten auf den weg
gebracht und wir werden das rentenniveau
bei 48 prozent stabilisieren damit es
nicht nach 2025 unterschritten wird das
ist eine wichtige leistung dieser region
wer sein leben lang gearbeitet und
beiträge gezahlt hat der muss sich auf
seine oder ihre rente verlassen können
das ist ein kernversprechen des
sozialstaates und wir werden das
erneuern
in diesen zeiten wo große veränderungen
stattfinden da ist es umso wichtiger
dass sich alle verlassen können auf
sicherheit und zusammenhalt wir
entlasten übrigens auch die unternehmen
vor allem diejenigen die jetzt mit dem
krieg und den hohen energiekosten zu
kämpfen haben und haben ein schutzschild
errichtet und betreibt das betrieben bei
bedarf mit zuschüssen bürgschaften oder
günstigen krediten unter die arme zu
greifen
mit dem ähnlichen instrumenten haben es
geschafft durch die korona pandemie zu
kommen und es ist gelungen arbeitsplätze
zu erhalten das ist eine gute botschaft
vor allem wenn wir jetzt sagen können
die beschäftigung ist gegenwärtig höher
als vor der pandemie es zeigt wenn ein
land zusammenhält dann kann man auch
durch schwere krisen kommen und diesen
weg dann wir weiter verfolgen
aber ich sage ganz offen
natürlich ist damit das problem
steigender preise noch nicht gelöst
denn der preisanstieg hat eine ganze
reihe von ursachen ganz vorn der von
russland angezettelten krieg
was machen sie der von russland
angezettelte gehen
er heizt die energie und rohstoffpreise
an die internationalen lieferketten sind
oft noch durch die pandemie gestört
insbesondere in asien man sollte sich
nur einmal die vorstellung
vergegenwärtigen von den vielen schiffen
in den container hilfen chinas
insbesondere in shanghai und natürlich
haben die milliardenschweren
konjunkturpakete die viele länder nicht
nur wir aufgelegt haben dazu geführt
dass es eine höhere nachfrage gibt zum
beispiel nach rohstoffen
noch sind also diese preissteigerung
wahrscheinlich auf solche einmaligen
shops zurückzuführen aber wir müssen
aufpassen
aber wir müssen aufpassen dass daraus
keine dauerhafte entwicklung mit zu
hohen inflationsrate bei allem was wir
heute und auch künftig tun ist eins klar
kreditfinanzierte dauersubventionen sind
keine lösung zumal wir nächstes jahr die
verfassungsmäßig vorgeschriebenen
schuldenbremse wieder beachtet werden
ziel muss also sein den inflationsdruck
nachhaltig zu mildern und zugleich
behalten wir weiterhin die finanzielle
lage von rentnern rentnern von
grundsicherungsempfänger von
studentinnen und studenten und familien
genau im blick auch die arbeitnehmern
und arbeitnehmer fragen sich was sie
sich noch werden leisten können
die tarifpartner in der chemieindustrie
haben kürzlich einen sehr interessanten
weg gewählt
beschlossen wurden gestiegene preise
schnell und substanziell auszugleichen
über eine einmalige sonderzahlung auch
in der stahlindustrie wird darüber
gerade diskutiert auch in anderen
tarifen zum beispiel passieren haben
einmalige zahlung haben zahlung eine
rolle gespielt
die gute idee dahinter ist den
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmern
finanziell luft zu verschaffen ohne die
arbeitgeber zu überfordern und
inflationsrisiken anzuheizen
ich habe mich deshalb zusammen mit allen
verantwortlichen der regierung zu einem
ungewöhnlichen schritt entschlossen ich
möchte die arbeitnehmer- und
arbeitnehmer ihre gewerkschaften und die
arbeitgeber zu einer konzertierten
aktion zusammenrufen
das hat schon einmal geholfen dass wir
zusammen gestanden haben gewerkschaften
arbeitgeber staat auch viele andere die
verantwortung in diesem land haben um
mit einer schwierigen herausforderung
umzugehen und ich finde es ist richtig
wenn instrumente der zusammenarbeit und
des zusammenhalts von unternehmen von
beschäftigten von gewerkschaften
unternehmerverbänden von start von
kommunen von allen institutionen schon
einmal in schwierigen laden geholfen
haben zu sagen hier muss erneut
zusammengestanden werden und
herausgefunden werden wie wollen wir mit
dieser preisentwicklung umgehend ich bin
dazu bereit dass wir uns so
zusammentreffen
natürlich wird das keine aktivität sein
wo wir uns treffen und mal reden da wird
ganz konkret gesprochen und ich will
auch sagen alle werden etwas beitragen
müssen die sozialpartner die arbeitgeber
selbstverständlich denn sie haben eine
große verantwortung dafür dass die
finanzkraft ihrer beschäftigten groß
genug ist aber auch wir als gemeinschaft
und der staat und deshalb ist es eben
umso wichtiger dass wir das miteinander
machen wir brauchen eine gezielte
krankheit kraftanstrengung in einer ganz
außergewöhnlichen situation und wir sind
dazu bereit wir wollen eine konzertierte
aktion gegen den preisdruck
das ist natürlich keine lohn
verhandlungsrunde das machen die
tarifpartner aber es geht darum das
miteinander zu besprechen und ich weiß
aus den gesprächen mit den
verantwortlichen im gewerkschaften und
arbeitgeberverbänden und
unternehmensverbänden dass sie das sehr
begrüßen wenn wir genau das jetzt machen
die groner pandemie hat uns gezeigt wie
wichtig gesellschaftlicher zusammenhalt
ist ich wünsche mir dass wir das
bewahren die aktuelle infektions lage
verschafft uns zeit zum handeln wir
nutzen sie intensiv um uns und unser
gesundheitssystem gut auf herbst und
winter vorzubereiten und sie stellen
unser gesundheitssystem so auf dass es
zukunftssicher ist dazu gehört die
gesetzliche krankenversicherung
verlässlich zu finanzieren
darauf können sich die patienten und
patienten aber auch die beschäftigten im
gesundheitswesen verlassen die in den
vergangenen zweieinhalb jahren so
unglaublich viel geleistet hatten haben
für unser land und wir werden sie nicht
vergessen und sie weiter unterstützen
weil der zusammenhalt so wichtig ist
werden auch sozialreform weiter eine
rolle spielen es ist nicht so dass das
alles jetzt verschwindet hinter dem
krieg herr merz sondern es bleibt gerade
in dieser situation ganz ganz wichtig
dass wir etwas für den zusammenhalt tun
und deshalb werden wir die reformen
weiter voran bringen die wir uns als
regierung vorgenommen haben das
bürgergeld mit dem wir auf beratung
unterstützung setzen statt auf unnötige
bürokratie und und komplizierte
antragsverfahren und die
kindergrundsicherung die
unübersichtliche vielzahl
unterschiedlicher familienleistung
zusammenführen und verbessern soll alles
beides wird weiter vorangebracht
kinder und jugendliche die in armut
aufwachsen darf es an einem so reichen
land wie deutschland nicht geben das ist
ein grundsatz der für diese regierung
unabdingbar itt
und selbstverständlich gehört dazu auch
dass wir jetzt
voran bringen was wir uns letztes jahr
vorgenommen haben
nämlich dass diejenigen die am wenigsten
verdienen einen besseren lohn bekommen
der mindestlohn wird ab oktober auf
zwölf euro in der stunde steigen es war
ein langer kampf jetzt wird das realität
das versprechen ist umgesetzt
wir wissen alle dass zwölf euro in der
stunde keine großen sprünge erlauben
aber es ist eine erleichterung für viele
die sehr sehr wenig geld haben gerade
wenn jetzt die preise steigen und es
macht einen unterschied für sechs
millionen bürgern und bürger was für
eine aussage über unser land und was
hier verdient wird aber wie dringlich
ist diese reform gut dass jetzt kommt
ihre kolleginnen und kollegen faire
löhne sind das eine aber viele bürger
machen bürger stellen sich
grundsätzlichere fragen wie sicher ist
der arbeitsplatz wenn energie teurer
wird und lieferketten unsicherer wie
geht es weiter mit dem industrieland
deutschland
ich kann das gut verstehen und wir
wissen alle dass wir vor einer zweiten
industriellen revolution stehen nur ein
beispiel um in zukunft mit sauberen
strom betrieben zu werden braucht ein
chemie standort wie ludwigshafen mit
basf in etwa die strommenge von acht bis
neun windparks auf see
das klingt viel und das ist es auch
die gute nachricht ist schon vor den
kriegsbeginn in der ukraine hatte die
bundesregierung ein zukunftsplan um das
industrieland deutschland bis 2045 co2
neutral zu machen und dieser brand gilt
heute immer noch mehr als vorher
zwei dinge sind dafür entscheidend
erstens versorgungssicherheit energie
muss immer verfügbar sein 24 stunden am
tag 365 tage im jahr
die bundesregierung hat zuletzt
erhebliche fortschritte durchgesetzt um
unabhängig vom russischen gast zu werden
schwimmende flüssiggasterminals werden
kurzfristig bereit stehen mit einem
eigenen gesetz beschleunigen wir den
ausbau so dass in wenigen monaten und
nicht in jahren und jahrzehnten die
nötige infrastruktur errichtet wird
erschließen neue bezugsquellen
erst vorige woche habe ich dazu
gespräche in afrika geführt wir reden
auch mit norwegen mit kanada die usa und
katar
und terminals und leistung sondern
künftig auch für wasserstoff genutzt
werden denn darin liegt die zukunft
zweitens der ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien wird massiv beschleunigt
das oster paket ist bereits
verabschiedet zwei weitere pakete
folgendem sommer und herz und wir wollen
die dauer der verwaltungsverfahren
mindestens halbieren und das
was will ich an dieser stelle auch
sicher sagt wir werden uns nicht den
schneid abkaufen lassen meine damen und
herren nicht von den lobbyisten nicht
von den bedenkenträgern und auch mächtig
von den verteidigern des status quo denn
wenn wir erst einmal anfangen dinge auf
die zeitschiene zu schieben dann werden
wir niemals rechtzeitig fertig werden es
ist zu lang wir haben die zeit dafür
nicht mehr dieses jahr ist das jahr der
entscheidung und die entscheidung werden
wir klopfen
mit meinen kolleginnen und kollegen und
aus den niederlanden dänemark belgien
und dem kommissionspräsidenten von
allein haben wir kürzlich die weichen
gestellt um aus nordseewind so etwas zu
machen wäre ein riesiges windenergie
kraftwerk das gleiche wollen wir für die
ostsee erreichen und die kommission hat
auch ihren beitrag geleistet mit dem
paket repower eu das dazu beitragen soll
dass viele dinge schneller gehen neben
vielen fragen die jetzt von einigen im
vordergrund diskutiert werden ist ja
eine sache dabei ganz zu trauen es
sollen noch einmal neue möglichkeiten
der beschleunigung beinhalten damit
verfahren einfacher werden und wird die
dinge besser voranbringen können auch
darüber haben wir bei der sondertagung
des europäischen rates gesprochen und es
bleibt ein ziel für ganz europa was für
uns unmittelbar geld wir wollen energie
unabhängigkeit erreichen so schnell wie
möglich das wissen wir ist diesen tagen
ganz ganz dringend angesichts des
russischen angriff
und wir wollen vollständige co2
neutralität bis 2045 erreichen das ist
machbar beides gehört zusammen es
schließt ein anderer nicht aus und wir
werden beides erreichen
natürlich wird dazu dass wir auch jetzt
die grundlagen dafür legen all das
voranzubringen was für unser land
wichtig ist bei forschungen innovation
bei digitalisierung wo wir mehr tempo
brauchen bei der aus und weiterbildung
und deshalb schaffen wir ein
qualifizierungs geld deshalb wollen wir
neue aufstiegsmöglichkeiten schaffen und
chancengerechtigkeit
wir schaffen eine startchance programm
wir bauen die ganztagsbetreuung an
schulen aus an grundschulen die
bafög-reform läuft und wir wollen uns
für eine ausbildungsgarantie einsetzen
damit jugendlichen einen berufseinstieg
nicht verwehrt bleibt alles gast
investitionen
denn wir brauchen die diese investition
in unsere zukunft wir brauchen die
besten der finderin die weltbesten
ingenieure und gut ausgebildete
facharbeiter rinnen und facharbeiter
ich habe eingangs über die erwartungen
der bürgerinnen bürger gesprochen wäre
fragen und sorgen die wir in den
mittelpunkt unserer politik stellen und
die aktuell größte sorge ist ganz
unbedingt der furchtbaren krieg den
russland gegen die ukraine begonnen hat
uns alle schmerzen die schmerz die opfer
dieses verbrecherischen krieges der ihn
schon fast 100 tagen wird mit jedem tag
steigen die opferzahlen
mit jedem tag werden mehr städte und
orte im trümmerwüste verwandelt
angesichts der russischen banken und
artillerie und deshalb ist so wichtig
dass wir uns über das einig sind was wir
erreichen und putin darf und wird diesen
krieg nicht gewinnen
und es gibt jetzt eine situation in der
immer wieder darüber diskutiert wird was
die kriegsziele sind unsere unser ziel
ist dass putin nicht gewinnt unser ziel
ist dass die ukraine sich verteidigen
kann und damit erfolgreich ist aber ich
will ausdrücklich sagen ich will
ausdrücklich sagen es ist überheblich
und es ist unangemessen und es ist
völlig fehl am platze wenn hier zu lange
darüber diskutiert wird was die ukraine
richtigerweise zu entscheiden hat ich
sage es mit dem amerikanischen
präsidenten über die ukraine entscheiden
die ukraine ukraine und niemand sonst
ihr herz
man muss fielen genau zuhören was sie da
machen und dann höre ich viel was mir
nicht gefällt ich höre auch vier aus
anderen den andern ländern was
diskutiert wird das will ich
ausdrücklich sagen da gibt es den einen
oder anderen der vielleicht auch denkt
so könnte das doch gelingen dann ist die
sache endlich vorbei aber das kann nicht
sein wir werden die ukraine ukrainer so
lange unterstützen wie das erforderlich
ist mit all den möglichkeiten die wir
auf den weg gebracht haben
putin darf seine ziele nicht erreichen
er darf nicht mit seinem konzept
durchkommen mit einem brutalen
militärischen einsatz ein land zu
erobern oder teile davon das ist
imperialismus und den werden wir in
europa nicht akzeptieren
gestern reisten unsere tiefgreifende
sagte es sind übrigens die
weitreichendsten sanktionen die jemals
gegen ein so großes land weltweit
verhängt worden sind es sind sehr
wirksame aktion auch das muss dazu
gesagt werden und sitzt interaktionen
mit dem putin niemals gerechnet hat weil
es sanktionen sind die
ausgeschlossenheit entstanden sind und
gerade dadurch ihre wirksamkeit
entfalten diese geschlossenheit müssen
wir bewahren
und deshalb ist es gut dass
sich der europäische rat gestern nach
dem 5 sanktionspaket die vorher
beschlossen waren auf ein sechstes
verständigt hat mit vielen weiteren sehr
detaillierten sanktionen an dem wir
lange gearbeitet haben und auch mit
einem ölembargo das dazugehört ich bin
froh dass diese entscheidung jetzt
getroffen worden ist
und steigen zum herbst aus der dem
import russischer kohle aus und für uns
in deutschland gilt trotz der ausnahme
für die pipeline anrainer wir werden
unverändert daran arbeiten bis zum
jahresende auch aus dem import von ole
von öl auszusteigen das bleibt
unverändert unser ziel
außerdem unterstützen wir die ukraine
finanziell mit sehr sehr viel mittel
gerade erst haben wir eine milliarde
zugesagt im rahmen der g7 eine direkte
zahlung aus deutschland die dazu
beitragen soll dass die ukraine dieser
situation per werden kann der see der
gefahr herr werden kann der sie
ausgesetzt ist und
neben der wirtschaftlichen und
finanziellen unterstützung
liefern wir auch waffe
eines will ich klarstellen
deutschland muss sich da nicht
verstecken
wir liefern kontinuierlich von beginn
des krieges an
und unmittelbar nach kriegsbeginn haben
wir diese entscheidung getroffen und mit
einer langjährigen breit staatspraxis in
deutschland gebrochen es war eine
richtige entscheidung aber es war eine
mutige neue entscheidung dieser
regierung meine damen und herren
und weil sie ja nur fragen durch die
landschaft getänzelt sind herr merz noch
mal der hinweis
es ist eine regierung die von der cdu
geführt worden ist diese staatspraxis
die letzten jahre hatte ich will das
nicht kritisieren aber so zu tun als sei
das nicht irgendein ganz besonders
weitreichender schritt gewesen dass wir
das jetzt gemacht haben das ist nicht in
ordnung und auch nicht vernünftig
zeitenwende das ist der furchtbare
imperialistische angriff russlands auf
sein nachbarland das unschuldig
überfallen worden ist dass wir darauf
reagieren
das sind weitreichende maßnahmen und zu
diesen weitreichenden maßnahmen zählte
schon als allererstes das wird diese
staatspraxis verändert haben ich
verstehe nicht wie da immer wieder von
ihm vorgetragen würde es sei nichts
passiert allein das ist eine massive
ender und der politik in deutschland
wenige tage nach kriegsausbruch haben
die flugabwehr raketen und panzer
abwehrwaffen geliefert also genau das
was zu dem zeitpunkt am dringendsten
nötig war dazu kommen bislang mehr als
15 millionen schuss munition
hunderttausend handgranaten über 5000
panzer abwärme umfangreiches
sprengmaterial
maschinengewehre dutzende lastwagen
ladungen mit sonstigen relevanten gütern
zum beispiel zur drohen hat mehr für
mobilität kommunikation und zur
verpflegung und versorgung verwundeter
gemeinsam mit dänemark haben wir der
ukraine auf ihren wunsch hin 54
modernisierte gepanzerte
truppentransporter gelegt hat über einen
ersten ringtausch mit unseren
tschechischen freunden bekommt die
ukraine vertrautes gerät britischer
bauart zunächst 20 kampfpanzer t 72 wir
sorgen für ersatz für tschechien weitere
gespräche laufen
erst gestern habe ich mit dem
griechischen ministerpräsidenten
mitsotakis verabredet dass griechenland
schützenpanzer aus ehemaligen informer
beständen liefern wird und wird dafür
die griechischen bestände mit deutschen
schützenpanzern auffüllen und auch das
sollte nicht
vergessen und beiseite getan werden
zu unserer unterstützung gehört auch
dass die bundeswehr bislang 168
besonders schwer verwundete ukrainische
soldaten ausgeflogen und hier in
deutschland behandelt hat
wir helfen als ein umfangreicher weise
und das könnte auch zur kenntnis
genommen werden und nicht durch fragen
in frage gestellt werden die einfach mit
fakten nichts zu tun haben das ist ja
nur eine flucht aus der tatsache dass
die realität mit dem was sie hier in
senioren nicht übereinstimmt dass sie
fragen stellen um nicht zugeben zu
müssen dass die frage beantworten wäre
und zwar sehr gut
aber es gibt weiter
in der letzten woche hat die ukraine den
vertrag mit der rüstungsindustrie über
die gebhard flaig panzer unterzeichnet
die rund dreiwöchige schulung läuft
dieser tage an und
das will ich ausdrücklich sagen die
wurden von der ukraine gewünscht ich
habe in den talkshows dieser republik
gehört das gesagt wurde die wollen das
gar nicht hier im bundestag haben das
auch welche erzählt ganz naseweis haben
sie berichtet wie sie eben über
terminvereinbarung ehrlicherweise dass
barney und zu keinem zeitpunkt richtig
dass es eine hochwirksame eine hoch
schwere waffe um diesen komischen
begriff zu benutzen und sie wird
eingesetzt werden in der ukraine
eine oder andere könnte ja mal seine
ganzen äußerung die da in der hitze des
gefechts in diesem fall so gesagt hat
noch einmal überprüfen da ist ganz schön
viel was einfach mit der wirklichkeit
nichts zu tun hat dabei und es kommt
diese waffe mit einer erstausstattung
von 59.000 schuss munition und das
reicht für 1200 bekämpfung vorgänger da
habe ich ja auch wieder welche gehört
und gelesen die gesagt haben dass seine
artillerie waffe mit der man nicht zum
beispiel flugzeuge bekämpft oder drogen
die reinen bedrohen sondern das sei
etwas das einfach darum zu nutzen würde
in die gegend zu schießen und
anderswohin das ist nicht richtig
gewesen und trotzdem durften hier leute
überall in deutschland diesen krams
erzählen wo leben wir eigentlich und was
macht eigentlich das für einen sinn
neben den kopf in den kommenden wochen
werden wir in der ukraine eng abgestimmt
mit den niederländern 12 der modernsten
panzerhaubitzen der welt liefern die
ausbildung ukrainischer soldaten daran
wird in wenigen tagen abgeschlossen sein
und es sind wirklich sehr moderne waffen
sehr schwere waffen was sollen abgesehen
davon dass das abschießen von flugzeugen
mit luftabwehrraketen auch ein schwerer
vorgang ist aber was soll denn anderes
schwere machte sein als zb gepard oder
die panzerhaubitze das ist doch einfach
dahergeredet es zeigt dass sie davor
tragen
in den kommenden wochen werden wir der
ukraine eng abgestimmt mit den
niederländern
wenn wir in den kommenden wochen werden
wir auch weitere waffen liefern zum
beispiel hat die bundesregierung aktuell
entschieden dass wir mit dem system iris
t das modernste flugabwehrsystem liefern
über das deutschland verfügt damit
versetzen die die ukraine in die lage
eine ganze großstadt vor russischen
luftangriffen zu schützen auch das ist
eine entscheidung dieser bundesregierung
ferner werden wir in der ukraine ein
hochmodernes ordnungs radar liefern das
feindliche auch witzen bahrain kippen
atelier aufklärt auch das ist eine
entscheidung die wir getroffen haben und
die die sicherheit der ukraine mit
modernstem gerät sicherstellen wird
alles was sie sagen ist nicht richtig
wir machen das was mögliches allen
regionen meiden
präsident biden
präsident biden hat gerade ein sehr sehr
lesenswerten und sehr wohl durchdachten
beitragen der new york times geschrieben
über die unterstützung die die usa
leisten und die verbündeten der usa mit
dem die usa immer eng abgestimmt handeln
das will ich übrigens sagen ist aus
meiner sicht eine wirklich
beeindruckende qualität unserer
transatlantischen beziehungen dass wir
wirklich intensiv miteinander abgestimmt
sind dass wir uns sorgfältig absprechen
dass wir gemeinsam hat und angesichts
der verlagerung des gefechts in den
osten der ukraine herr präsident biden
gesagt
man will über das hinaus was bisher
geliefert worden ist
die möglichkeit nutzen mehrfach
raketenwerfer zur verfügung zu stellen
er hat gesagt er
werde keine waffen liefern stehen die
ukraine in der lage wäre nach russland
zu schießen aber das was notwendig ist
mit dann dieser distanz auch von
russland in der ukraine genutzten
solchen paket verfangen das werden die
usa tun wir sind mit ihr seit tagen
darüber im gespräch und wir haben mit
den usa besprochen dass das was dann
haben unsere technischen möglichkeiten
ist auch beigetragen wird auch das hört
zu unseren entscheidungen
und natürlich ist alleine dieser aufsatz
wert sehr sorgfältig diskutiert zu
werden denn die besonders die fähigkeit
abzuwählen das für und wider zu
erörtern
das wünschte ich mir auch von der
opposition in diesem deutschen bundestag
wir haben jedenfalls im geleitzug mit
unseren verbündeten so habe ich es oft
gesagt und diesen geleitzug habe ich
eben beschrieben er wird auch weiter
unsere politik bestimmen natürlich weiß
ich dass das eine situation ist in der
das für und wider mit großen heißem
herzen hat er wird aber es gibt auch
klare haltungen dabei und natürlich ist
es gut sich hinzustellen zudem zu
gehören die immer sagen alles noch mehr
davon noch was davon noch was genau so
wie es ganz einfach ist zu sagen gar
nichts aber das was man tun muss ist
genau der weg den diese regierung
eingeschlagen hat große entschlossenheit
mut und kluge abwägung das ist das
vertreten
und damit bin ich bei dem liebe
kolleginnen kollegen
was wir mit dem sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr erreichen
ziel ist eine leistungsfähige und
fortschrittliche bundeswehr eine
bundeswehr die ihren kernauftrag die
landesverteidigung erfüllen kann weil
sie ausreichend ausgestattet ist und ich
wiederhole was sich am anfang gesagt
habe die versäumnisse der letzten 16
jahren von csu und cdu
verteidigungsminister und der dortigen
regierung stellen die werden jetzt
aufgebracht und aufgeholt
dass jeder soldat in holzschlag es war
die csu cds und cdu die die spart zeit
bei der bundeswehr begonnen haben das
ist die wahrheit
gleichwohl ich bedanke mich bei allen
die in den letzten tagen mitgeholfen
haben dass wir diese entscheidung
zustande bringen können das so
konstruktiv und da über parteigrenzen
hinweg verhandelt worden ist denn das
was ihr hinbekommen ist ein
quantensprung
und es hat auch eine konsequenz die
bundeswehr wird wohl dann die größte
konventionelle armee im europäischen
nato system
und wir werden auch alles dafür
beitragen dass wir uns auch ansonsten
weiter verbessern was unsere
sicherheitsarchitektur betrifft zum
beispiel wenn es um fragen der
cybersicherheit geht und deshalb finde
ich müssen wir den moment der hier
stattfindet auch genau verstehen es ist
anders als in früheren zeiten wo man in
paris sind warschau in london in
washington oder prag angst und sorge
hatte wenn die bundeswehr so viel
stärker waren die deutsche armee sondern
es ist erleichterung was dort zu spüren
ist alle sind sehr beeindruckt von
diesem schritt endlich sagen sie endlich
übernimmt deutschland die
sicherheitspolitische verantwortung die
es im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
hatte und zwar von einer ampel
angehört wir wollen helfen
ist die richtige haben wir doch die
zeiten beendet und wir geben sie die wir
kolleginnen und kollegen wir bringen in
ordnung was nicht in ordnung war und
deshalb ist es auch so richtig bei
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten es
verdienen dass sie eine gute bundeswehr
haben genauso wie die bürgerinnen und
bürger des landes denn es geht um
sicherheit und wir haben die
verantwortung die sicherheit unseres
landes und unseres bündnisses zu
gewährleisten
herberg sie haben darüber berichtet dass
hier als ich das sagte beifall
geklatscht wurde auch aus den reihen
ihrer fraktion dafür bedanke ich mich
wie ich mich übrigens wirklich ernstlich
gedanke dass es möglich war konstruktiv
das ergebnis hier zu verhandeln ich
möchte mich auch bei allen die mit
verhandelt haben intensiv bedanken weil
ich weiß es geht immer auch um konkrete
person in der lage sind dank das zu tun
was notwendig ist aber dass
aber dass
das will ich an dieser stelle dann doch
auch sagen so zu tun
so zu tun
als wäre das jetzt alles schon mal
passiert weil die rede gehalten wurde
vor drei monaten
das ist ein irrtum das ist die größte
veränderung der sicherheitspolitischen
architektur dieses landes und ich bin
stolz dass wir das diese regierung sie
auf den weg bringen kann ich bin dankbar
dass die opposition dabei hilft
[Applaus]
1 will ich hier noch kurz sagen weil das
für mich wichtig ist
internationale solidarität ist keine
einbahnstraße
und deshalb
habe ich sehr bewusst die aufstrebenden
demokratien des globalen südens indien
indonesien südafrika senegal und
argentinien als partnerländer zum g 7
gipfel in ellmau eingeladen
denn das darf uns nicht passieren
dass wir diese länder als bündnispartner
verlieren und das ist ja eine große
gefahr angesichts der auswirkungen des
krieges der gefahren für hunger und
sicherheit und energieversorgung dieser
länder und deshalb ist es wichtig dass
wir darüber nicht hinweg sehen der krieg
ist aus der perspektive mancher dieser
länder ganz weit weg aber die
konsequenzen ganz nah wir müssen ihnen
helfen und das werden wir tun in größter
solidarität und gleichzeitig die
botschaft aussenden die auch ausgesandt
werden muss in jedem gespräch es ist
putins krieg der diese krise verursacht
und nichts anderes
zum schluss
wir leben mit einer herausforderung wie
sie die bundesrepublik deutschland noch
nicht in dieser art gekannt hat wir
müssen etwas dafür tun dass wir in
dieser besonderen situation auch
besonders handle und dass durch diese
haushalt aus
das sind nicht meine worte sondern die
worte meiner vorgängerin aus dem jahr
seinerzeit hat die bundeskanzler und
damit eine neuverschuldung begründet die
deutlich höher lag als die
neuverschuldung im aktuellen
haushaltsentwurf
anders als damals haben wir es heute
allerdings nicht nur mit der pandemie
und ihren folgen zu tun sondern
zusätzlich mit einem krieg in europa mit
einer globalen energie- und
nahrungsmittelkrise und weltweit
steigenden preisen in diesen unsicheren
zeiten sorgen wir mit dem haushalt 2022
und dem sondervermögen bundeswehr für
sicherheit und zugleich stellen wir die
weichen für den aufbruch in die zukunft
das erwarten die bürgerinnen und bürger
dafür steht die bundesregierung dafür
steht dieser ausland schön dann
und das war die rede des bundeskanzlers
der heute für seine verhältnisse recht
deutlich wurde dabei vor allem die union
attackierte scholz lobte die politik der
ampel das sondervermögen zu die
bundeswehr und die entlastungs paket
beim thema ukraine krieg wiederholte er
dass putin diesem tag nicht gewinnen
dürfen wie und wann der krieg beendet
werden das entscheide nur die ukraine
selber und den vorwurf deutschland
liefere keine schweren waffen
widersprach er dement nannte konkrete
beispiele und kündigte die lieferung
weiterer schwerer waffen
es folgt nun anders weil die
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp
die
nächste rednerin für die afg fraktion dr
alice weiter
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr bundeskanzler sehr geehrte
damen und herren es ist sehr schön dass
sie sich zwischen opposition und
regierung so gut verstehen dass sie zu
einem kompromiss gefunden haben aber uns
liegen alle diese anträge gar nicht vor
haben wir hier geschlafen oder am 7
schlafen was ist hier eigentlich los
legen sie doch die anträge vor dass wir
sie auch hier vernünftig abstimmen
können aber zurück zum haushalt ist eine
haushaltsdebatte wenig hat herr merz
über den haushalt geredet aber diese
haushalt ist ein dokument der
abgehobenheit der realitätsverweigerung
und der ignoranz gegenüber dem zustand
des landes und seiner menschen
die regierungskoalition muss sich an die
welt zu retten die energieversorgung für
ein industrieland im alleingang neu zu
regeln und das klima in 50 oder 100
jahren zu regeln aber das eigene land
und seine menschen werden ruiniert
sie reden von zeitenwende aber sie
handeln nicht danach die kapseln sich in
ihrer ideologischen fantastereien ein
von klimaschutz energiewende
multikulturalismus diversität und
verweigern den blick auf die realität
deutschland steckt in einer
fundamentalen wirtschafts- finanz- und
staatskrise die alles bisher dagewesene
übertrifft
und dennoch
und dennoch geben sie das geld mit
vollen händen aus sie verteilen es in
alle welt klima milliarden für ihn denn
hier
milliarden waffen milliarden für die
ukraine dar sie blähen den staatsapparat
noch weiter auf sie schaffen neue
regierungsposten und genehmigen sich
großzügig noch mehr stellen in den
ministerien und verwaltung für die
eigenen bürger und steuerzahler bleiben
dagegen nur trostpflaster und alibi
politik die deutschen zahlen mit die
höchsten steuern und abgaben der
westlichen welt sie bekommen dafür
miserable renten und einen zunehmenden
funktionsfähigen staat einen staat der
immer weniger in der lage ist seine
kernaufgaben wahrzunehmen die
aufrechterhaltung von
rechtsstaatlichkeit und öffentliche
ordnung die gewährleistung von innerer
und äußerer sicherheit der sich aber
immer dreister und über griffiger in das
privatleben der bürger einmischt sie
bevormundet und ihn dafür immer tiefer
in die tasche greift die krise in der
unser land steckt ist nicht vom himmel
gefallen sie ist politisch gemacht
inflation energieknappheit
explodierender energiepreise
gestörte lieferketten fachkräftemangel
und überlastete sozialkassen sind die
folge politischer fehlentscheidungen und
nein sie können die verantwortung dafür
nicht allein putins angriffskrieg
schieben die ursachen liegen tiefer
die fatalen fehlentscheidungen wurden
früher getroffen und sie sind vor allem
in berlin und brüssel gefallen die
galoppierende inflation ist die quittung
für exzessive schulden machen und für
die geldschwemme und null zinspolitik
der europäischen zentralbank zur
subventionierung der euro hoch
schuldenstaaten 8 prozent inflation
heißt sparguthaben
rücklagen und rentenansprüche sind nach
sechs jahren nur noch die hälfte wert
die reallöhne sinken als folge der
inflation fast 40 prozent der deutschen
wissen gar nicht mehr wie sie ihren
lebensunterhalt bestreiten sollen was
haben sie dazu eigentlich gesagt was
haben sie an lösungen angeboten nicht
noch mehr bürokratische umverteilung ist
alles was diese ampel anzubieten hat
tank rabatt 9 euro ticket einmal zum
schüsse oder klima geld sind teure
bürokratische strohfeuer die nichts
bringen und ich muss es einfach so sagen
die nur ihre eigene unfähigkeit
kaschieren so
steigende energiepreise heizen die
inflation weiter antreiben mittelstand
und mittelschicht in die farm die
deutsche energie krise hat einer die
energiewende kohle und atom ausstieg
zeitgleich flotter strom aus wind und
sonne als ersatz für eine
grundlastfähige günstige
energieversorgung wie wir sie einmal
hatten in diesem land und dazu als
neueste idee aus dem hause haarweg die
beseitigung der erdgasinfrastruktur für
die wohnungs beheizung das konnte und
das kann nicht gut gehen sie aber
missbrauchen den krieg in der ukraine
um diesem irrweg noch zu beschleunigen
noch mehr geld dafür zu verbrennen und
noch mehr naturzerstörung durch
monströse windräder voranzutreiben die
deutschen energiekosten sind jetzt schon
die höchsten aller industrieländer ob
mit oder ohne ukraine krieg die
energiewende ist gescheitert und muss
schleunigst korrigiert werden und dazu
muss die erkenntnis kommen dass energie
sanktion gegen russland
kontraproduktiv sind und unserem land
mehr schaden zufügen als russland sehr
geehrte damen und herren und durch den
freiwilligen verzicht auf erdöl
lieferungen auf dem landweg das muss man
sich mal vorstellen
gefährden sie die treibstoffversorgung
im osten deutschlands um würden den
bürgern noch höhere energiepreise auf
den drohenden zusammenbruch der sozialen
sicherungssysteme vor dem der
bundesrechnungshof gerade in einem alarm
bericht gewarnt hat haben sie ebenfalls
keine antwort
unkontrollierte migration
löst weder fachkräftemangel noch
demografieprobleme und schon gar nicht
wenn man wahllos migration von
bildungsfernen und nicht integrierbaren
aus fremden kulturkreisen zulässt und
sogar noch gefördert
dagegen sind im vergangenen jahr
million menschen auf deutschland
ausgewandert nicht wenige sind
hochqualifizierte die für immer verloren
sind und dieser brain drain
diesem brain drain nehmen sie
achselzuckend hin und fahren fort mit
der negativen anreiz setzung für
qualifizierte arbeitnehmer so sieht die
politik aus und von den asyl zuwanderern
seit 2016 stichwort wir schaffen das
sind rund eine million immer noch eine
million zusätzliche kosten in unseren
sozialsystemen
was tun sie sie funktionieren die hartz
iv
leistungen durch streichung der
sanktionsmöglichkeiten zum de facto
grundeinkommen um und sie wollen diese
leistung im nächsten schritt nicht nur
für ukrainische
kriegsflüchtlinge sondern für alle asyl
einwanderer öffnen das heißt sie
beschleunigen diesem trend und
qualifizierte einwanderung noch und wer
dagegen 45 jahre bei einem durchschnitts
bruttolohn von
24.000 euro im jahr gearbeitet hat
landet gerade auf einem hartz iv niveau
und sie tun nichts um diese
offensichtliche schieflage zu beseitigen
und das rentensystem auf eine tragfähige
grundlage zu stellen und das ist der
offenbarungseid für die
sozialdemokratisch geführte andere
beginnen
wir brauchen
tatsächlich eine echte zeitenwende in
der deutschen politik und das bedeutet
abschied vom ideologischen illusion und
konzentration der staatsaufgaben und
ausgaben auf das wesentliche es ist
richtig und überfällig den auf rüstungs
und
investitionsstau der bundeswehr mit
zusätzlichen ausgaben anzugehen
jahrzehntelang wurde die armee
vernachlässigt und
heruntergewirtschaftet dafür tragen sie
alle vor allem aber ihre partei herr
merz die verantwortung 16 jahre lang hat
die union kanzlerin und
verteidigungsminister gestellt da ist es
schon mehr als scheinheilig sich hier
als retter und beschützer der bundeswehr
auf zu spielen und den soli und
den soli märz dass sie eben dargelegt
hat um zu funktionieren als sondersteuer
zur reparatur der eigens
heruntergewirtschafteten bundeswehr das
ist ein schlag ins gesicht für alle
steuerzahler
die bezeichnung sondervermögen für
zusätzliche schulden ist ebenfalls
irreführend warum nennen sie das
sondervermögen es sind sonder schulden
und das wäre ehrlicher dass diese
ausgabe im grundgesetz verankert werden
soll um sie aus der allgemeinen
staatsverschuldung hinaus zu rechnen ist
ein unnötiger und unlauterer bilanztrick
und das wissen sie ganz genau und besser
wäre es und der hafen steht die afd
überflüssige posten aus dem haushalt zu
streichen die sprechen hier von einem
rekordvolumen des haushaltes streichen
sie überflüssige posten und
konzentrieren sie die staatsausgaben auf
das wesentliche und niemand kann
behaupten dass dafür keine spielräume
vorhanden wären der staat hat in
deutschland nichts zu wenig geld sondern
zu viel das verstehen sich vielleicht
das konzept und ersetzt bei diesen
ausgaben die falschen prioritäten darum
geht es doch und der auf das vierfache
des vor krone haushalts
aufgeblasene etat des
gesundheitsministeriums
ist durch nichts zu rechtfertigen der
überforderte gesundheitsminister darf
also weiter milliarden nicht benötigter
impfdosen bestellen und anlasslose
massentest um veranlassen und unser land
hat gerade wahrhaftig andere sorgen als
die neuauflage fakten freier grundrechts
einschränkungen und rechtswidriger ins
kampagnen
viel geld wieder ausgegeben für
zensurmaßnahmen meinungs- kontrolle da
sind sie ja spitzenreiter und den
sogenannten kampf gegen rechts drängende
echte sicherheitsprobleme werden dagegen
herunter gespielt vor allem wenn es sich
um die importierte kriminalität handelt
deutschland braucht weder neue steuern
noch neue schulden um wieder auf die
beine zu kommen wir brauchen die
rückkehr zu soliden staatsfinanzen und
das erfordert mehr als folgenlose tweets
dieses bundesfinanzministers
stampfen wir lieber einige
lieblingsprojekte grüne und linke
ideologie und klientelpolitik ein dann
haben wir auch geld zur entlastung der
menschen und lassen wir den bürgern ihr
sauer verdientes geld in ihrem eigenen
portemonnaie dort ist es am besten
aufgehoben
gebt mir den bürgerlichen und
unternehmerischen
der unternehmerischen freiheit
wieder vorrang statt bevormundung und
kontrollwahn liebe ampel koalition und
gehen wir zurück zur realpolitik
setzen die interessen des eigenen landes
genau dahin wo sie hingehören und zwar
an die erste stelle ich bin da gibt es
heftige kritik von der regierung der
regierung von der afd dies weil sprach
von einer fundamentalen wirtschafts und
staatskrise die regierung gehe den
staatsapparat auf die deutschen würden
zu viel steuern zahlen zu niedrige
renten bekommen putins angriffskrieg sei
nicht alleine verantwortlich für die
inflation dies sei auch die folge
jahrelanger schuldenpolitik steigende
energiepreise die folge der energiewende
die regierung missbrauche den ukraine
trinkt für ihre politik der energiewende
es folgt nun britta haßelmann die
fraktionsvorsitzende von bündnis 90
grüne
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren bei der rede von herrn
merz habe ich gedacht die überschrift
lautet sagt einer dessen
bundestagsfraktion und bundesregierung
16 jahre verantwortung getragen hat und
uns allen im parlament und der
gesellschaft einen
riesenberg nicht erledigte aufgaben
hinterlassen hat meine damen und herren
vermerkt ich weiß nicht woher kann es
vielleicht doch im training oder nach
getaner rede schon weg aber
ein bisschen weniger männer eitelkeit
ein bisschen mehr selbstreflexion und
vor allen dingen meine damen und herren
ein bisschen mehr
gemeinsame verantwortung angesichts
dieser wirklich krisenhaften zeit wäre
notwendig und wichtig und angemessen
der erde zu legen
seit fast 100 tagen tobt putins
angriffskrieg in der ukraine
es kann keine aussprache geben um ohne
diesem thema eine große relevanz eine
große aufmerksamkeit zu widmen denn die
lage ist dramatisch morde an und
klinischen zivilistinnen vergewaltigung
vertreibung massive
menschenrechtsverletzungen durch die
russische seite sind kriegsalltag
geworden und die große sorge treibt
wahrscheinlich nicht nur mich sondern
uns alle oben es gibt irgendwie eine
gewisse gewöhnung an das an dass sich
niemand gewinnen darf nennt mich diese
grausamkeit dieses krieges
und der putin
obwohl er die offensive in den letzten
tagen deutlich erhöht hat seine
kriegsziele nicht erreicht und das liegt
an der ukraine an dem an der art wie die
ukraine durchhält wie sie kämpft die
zeit läuft gegen putin mit jedem
weiteren tag die menschen in der ukraine
kämpfen und verteidigung gelang der
demokratie ihre freiheit und russland
muss diesen krieg sofort stoppen und
alle kampfhandlungen einstellen dass es
eine wichtige forderung europas aller
der weltgemeinschaft auch nach fast 100
tagen krieg meine damen und herren zudem
führt nicht den krieg gegen die ukraine
sondern auch gegen unsere gemeinsamen
europäischen und internationalen werte
menschenrechte demokratie freiheit
selbstbestimmung dafür kämpft die
ukraine und wir werden nicht akzeptieren
dass putin die europäische
friedensordnung zerstört mit dem recht
des stärkeren grenzen zu verschieben mit
hunger die welt in geiselhaft zu nehmen
oder das rad der geschichte zurückdrehen
zu wollen und deshalb meine damen und
herren darf putin diesen krieg nicht
gewinnen wie es wichtig an dieser stelle
doch einmal deutlich zu sagen wir stehen
an der seite der ukraine ja wir machen
uns die daraus folgenden entscheidungen
nicht leicht wir nehmen die sorgen und
nöte und ängste vor einer ausweitung des
krieges sehr ernst auch wir hadern
manchmal auch wir wägen ab und ja
vielleicht
könnten manche entscheidungen auch
schneller getroffen werden aber wir
stehen an der seite der ukraine und
sagen ja zum recht auf
selbstverteidigung und zu
waffenlieferung zu schweren bach
lieferung zu denen wir ja gesagt haben
die gebraucht werden dringend gebraucht
werden und die zugesagt sind und auf den
weg gebracht werden meine damen und
herren wir sagen ja zu weiteren
sanktionen zum ende fossiler energien
aus russland es ist wichtig dass der
beschluss zum öl embargo endlich kommt
er hat lange gedauert aber jetzt ist er
da die rolle ungarns ist unrühmlich das
wissen wir alle aber wir werden die
ukraine jetzt weiter unterstützen beim
wiederaufbau und bei ihren weg in die
europäische gemeinschaft das ist klar
und auch dieses signal ist eindeutig von
uns hier im parlament ausgegangen und
auf ihren
kommen wir jetzt zu der frage deutsche
tragen besondere verantwortung für
frieden in europa und hier herr merz ich
meine es darf doch nicht ihr ernst sein
ein soli für die bundeswehr meine damen
und herren 16 jahre
regierungsverantwortung die gott sei
dank vorbei sind ein soli für die
bundeswehr nachdem die wunde wer so
abgewirtschaftet hat mit allen
entscheidungen allen
verteidigungsministern der cdu/csu in
den letzten 16 jahren ich hätte mir mehr
verantwortung von ihnen gewünscht dass
es klar und eindeutig wir deutschen
tragen eine besondere verantwortung für
frieden in europa unsere nachbarn und
verbündeten schauen auf uns erwarten
klarheit entschlossenheit und
gemeinsames handeln und auch deshalb ist
es wichtig dass dieser für uns nicht
einfacher kompromiss zum sondervermögen
jetzt gelungen ist und ausgehandelt ist
ein scheitern wäre keine option gewesen
meine damen und herren und das wissen
alle auch wenn ich als grüne
bundestagsfraktion ganz klar gesagt habe
die vorliegende fassung des kabinetts
wäre die bessere grundlage gewesen aber
es war klar wir brauchen eine zwei
drittel mehrheit im bundestag und
deshalb ist es wichtig und richtig dass
es hier zu einem ergebnis gekommen ist
ich nehme zur kenntnis dass leute wie
manfred weber weiter sind als ihre ganze
fraktion und allen voran als ihr
vorsitzender der jeder drin
darauf was wir eigentlich verankern
wollten die europäische verteidigung und
die cyber abwehr und das nicht einfach
nur benannt im test sondern durch geld
hinterlegt das schild manchen jetzt sehr
spät ein wir grüne fordern seit monaten
eine cyber sicherheitsstrategie mehr
geld für den zivilschutz an uns wird es
nicht scheitern dass es dringend
notwendig in dieser erweiterten
sicherheitsbegriff was die
bündnisfähigkeit angehen ist dringend
notwendig sie sind weit weit hinter der
aktuellen debatte in deutschland und in
europa mein gedanke
die einigung unterstreicht dass die
notlagen eine einigung zum
sondervermögen außerhalb der
schuldenbremse dann doch wirklich machen
bitte wir haben gerade gehört was herr
merz zu der frage schuldenbremse gesagt
hat wir haben auch berührt was er zu der
frage sondervermögen gesagt hat
schlüssig ist das alles nicht meine
damen und herren weil jetzt hilfe in der
lage ein sondervermögen aufzubauen für
die bundeswehr geht der etf also der
energie und klimafonds mit den 60
milliarden wird beim
bundesverfassungsgericht beklagt
gleichzeitig gleichzeitig lässt man ihn
aber stehen und nimmt ihn verdeckung
sämtlicher projekte der union so
funktioniert haushaltsberatung andere
cdu/csu und meine damen und herren aber
wir stehen vor ganz anderen
herausforderungen
und jetzt mit der union zu beschäftigen
auf dem weiteren weg werden wir zusammen
hier im haus hier in unserem land
darüber diskutieren müssen wie wir
unsere verantwortung besser gerecht
werden bei der wahrung von frieden und
sicherheit beim schutz der
menschenrechte bei der globalen
entwicklung beim globalen klimaschutz
und ich bin dankbar dass hier annalena
baerbock erste wegmarken gesetzt hat mit
der nationalen sicherheitsstrategie ich
bin auch dankbar dass robert habe in den
letzten tagen klar gesagt hat dass
investitionsgarantien
verweigert werden nachdem deutlich wurde
welche gravierenden
menschenrechtsverletzungen in china an
den abo-gebühren
begangen werden es ist deutlich geworden
es ist an der zeit klare haltung klaren
kompass und entschlossenes handeln zu
zeigen hier und jetzt und das tun wir in
dieser woche und unterstreichen das
nicht nur durch die beiden
entlastungspaket 'nicht nur durch die
sehr schwierige debatte zum
sondervermögen sondern auch durch die
entlastungs paket und den haushalt die
wir jetzt auf den weg bringen gemeinsam
1 am film eine art wären viele menschen
dem land spüren dass die kriegen groß
sind und dass es eine gemeinsame
verantwortung bräuchte mehr gemeinsame
verantwortung bräuchte diese krisen zu
bewältigen
jeder in seinen lebensalltag spürt es an
der kasse im supermarkt oder bei der
nebenkostenabrechnung und in dem kontext
da olaf scholz für die konzertierte
aktion angesprochen hat das ist das
angesichts der lage für ein signal wenn
ein großer wohnungsbaukonzern heute
ankündigt die mieten zu erhöhen ist dass
das signal einer sozialen
marktwirtschaft nein das ist es nicht
meine damen und herren wir haben zwei
große entlastungs paket auf den weg
gebracht als ampelkoalition viele
maßnahmen wie etwa das nun euro ticket
greifen ab heute 7 millionen verkaufte
tickets meine damen und herren sie sehen
die menschen wollen dass es angebote
gibt dem öffentlichen personennahverkehr
dass sie bezahlbar sind dann werden sie
auch genutzt das ist eine riesenchance
für uns hier auch um zu steuern was
dringend notwendig ist seit jahren
entlastungs paketen gezielt vor armut
betroffenen kindern mit einem sofort
zuschlag von 20 euro erwachsene in der
grundsicherung mit einer einmalzahlung
von 200 euro
jedes kind in familien 1100 euro das
wird ein einmaliger heizkostenzuschuss
in höhe von 270 euro aus gezeigt und in
der breite entlasten wir mit der
anhebung des grundfreibetrags der
energiepreis pauschale oder dem neuen
euro ticket allein in diesem jahr sind
das entlastung für bürgerinnen und
bürger von weit über 30 milliarden euro
meine damen und herren und das ist ein
wichtiges signal in krisenzeiten an den
bürgerinnen und bürger und ich bin froh
dass wir das als anti gemeinsam auf den
weg bringen eine daraus hervor und
klimakrise und die notwendige soziale
und ökologische transformation
wir haben verantwortung in dieser krise
übernommen und tun unser möglichstes
und das ist mit aller ernsthaftigkeit zu
tun wir wissen aber auch dass wir an
vielen anderen stellen dranbleiben
müssen dass wir da liefern müssen es ist
eine vielzahl der herausforderung die
zum handeln drängen und es ist auch der
berg den uns die union in 16 jahren
nicht erledigte aufgaben hinterlassen
hat der uns bringt meine damen und
herren die unmittelbar geld hast du dir
sind das eine die ampel print nötige
strukturelle veränderungen auf den weg
die abschaffung der eeg umlage oder eben
die einführung des gesetzlichen
mindestlohns
alles sehr wichtige sozialpolitische
maßnahmen um die notwendige
transformation zu begleiten und das ist
ein wichtiges signal an bürgerinnen und
bürger und weitere strukturelle
entlastung reformen liegen vor uns jedes
fünfte kind wird den da mut die
kindergrundsicherung muss eingeführt
werden wir haben riesenglück sowohl in
der frage der zukunft der
rentenversicherung als auch der
gesundheitsversorgung als auch der
pflegeversicherung übernommen runter
kommen sie und fordert diese regierung
auf in der rente was zu tun sie
eigentlich die letzten 16 jahre meine
damen und herren sind
ja es ist wirklich weiß aber strukturen
sind notwendig und die lücke in der gkv
von 20 milliarden euro die hätten sie
wohl sagt und nicht wir und die da unten
und erwartet
sie sagen sind sie im amt vorschläge zur
rente wo leben sie den herrn er hat sie
waren 16 jahre taten strabag ihre
aufgabe
und wie ich auch nicht durch ein paar
ja das ist doch ihre aufgabe weil wenn
sie verantwortung tragen in dieser
situation in dieser krise dank ist es
ihre aufgabe diese krisenbewältigung
mitzutragen diese erwartungen hat mich
an sie als demokratische funktion
und meine damen und herren
was ein notwendigen strukturreformen
wirklich vor uns liegt in fragen der
ökologischen transformation in fragen
der sozialen transformation ist nicht
durch ein halbes jahr regierung mal
gerade zu regeln und deshalb habe ich
auch gerade herr merz an ihre
verantwortung appelliert ich meine das
ganz ernst ganz große gesellschaftliche
aufgaben da sollten auch sie
verantwortung tragen
denn wir sind zum teil in dem
schlamassel weil sie ihn nicht bewältigt
haben weil sie betteln punkt haben und
das geht zum beispiel gerade die
bekämpfung der klimakrise an wo waren
sie denn die letzten 16 jahre wir haben
es alle gewusst dass ein umsteuern
dringend notwendig gewesen wäre der
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien wurde
blockiert die energie effizienz nicht
vorangebracht
energieeinsparung nicht nein sie haben
uns in diese zementierte abhängigkeit
der forcieren
daran sie uns gebracht die vielen
entscheidung und
1275 viele große baustellen gerade vor
uns wir können doch nicht darüber hinweg
sehen was sie in ihren in pakistan die
hitzerekorde die durch die wetter-
extreme selbst bei uns wir haben
dramatische folgen und wir haben vor
allen dingen den auftrag des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes ganz klar als
aufgabe für das parlament uns hier
gesetzt bekommen auch sie die bekämpfung
der klimakrise die frage der künftigen
generationen und ihrer freiheit ist bei
allen künftigen entscheidungen zu wahren
und zu belasten das ist unser auftrag
und den haben sie sich
verweigert also lassen sie heute beim
backen nicht so auf sondern tut sie mit
das wäre angesagt und meine damen und
herren wenn ich an diese ganzen wirklich
relevanten und großen veränderungen
denke dann ist doch klar dass das nicht
durch ein paar einsparungen hier oder da
oder zwei bekenntnisse zur
schuldenbremse zu regeln ist wir sind in
einer notlage und wir werden über
müssten wie wir aus dieser notlage mit
zukunftsinvestitionen rauskommen die
zentrale frage meine damen und herren
und da der weg ist hier und heute und
für die zukunft und wir haben im bereich
der internationalen verpflichtungen
dinge akzente gesetzt in diesem haushalt
aber bei einem 1 zu 1 prinzip sind wir
noch nicht nur deshalb geht es auch um
die globale verantwortung für uns alle
darüber wird weiter zu diskutieren sein
ich halte es für dringend geboten das
mit klaren kompass klare haltung und
entschlossenem handeln für die zukunft
in den nächsten monaten es weitergeht
und wir klare aufgaben vor uns liegen
die zu tun sind machen sie mit
entscheiden sie sich dafür auch
verantwortung zu übernehmen sie müssen
sie eigentlich spüren aus den letzten 16
jahren untätigkeit
das war britta haßelmann von den grünen
mit heftiger kritik an der union sie
fordert mehr selbstkritik von der cdu
csu die schließlich die letzten 16 jahre
an der macht gewesen sei hasselmann
lobte den komponisten sondervermögen
auch wenn die grünen gerne das thema
cybersicherheit mit dabei gehabt und
durch geld hinterlegt hätten weitere
reformen beim thema kindergrundsicherung
rente struktur seien nötig verursacht
seit das alles durch die
vorgängerregierung die union müsse nun
die krisenbewältigung betragen es
folgten fraktionsvorsitzende der linken
am ihrer mohammed ali
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin kollegen
und kollegen
38 der menschen in deutschland fällt es
zunehmend schwer die dinge des täglichen
bedarfs zu bezahlen man kann nicht mehr
von einer minderheit sprechen das sagte
anja kohl vor seiner sendung börse vor
acht butter kostet inzwischen über drei
euro song boom 05 euro milch im
discounter schon ein euro 20 frisches
obst und gemüse werden zunehmend zum
luxusgut
eine solche preissteigerung habe ich
seit langer zeit nicht mehr erlebt das
sagte mir neulich einen 93 jährige dame
aus meinem wahlkreis zum glück zurück
fahre sie kein auto mehr sagte sie die
spritpreise heute konnte sie mit ihrer
kleinen rente nicht bezahlen das neue
euro ticket das hält sie für eine gute
idee aber wo sie wohnt da fährt fast
kein bus und nicht so wie man sich das
chaos in der umsetzung mal anschaut dann
könnte man meinen an die steuer sei noch
im amt
von den 300 euro in der reportage wird
sie als rentnerin auch nichts sehen
anders übrigens als die minister
minister der bundesregierung auch sie
herr chance sie bekommen die energie
pauschale die alte dame nicht ja wie
abgehoben kann man eigentlich sein dass
doch wirklich ein skandal
und da wundern sie sich dass viele leute
zur wahl gehen weil sie das vertrauen in
politik verloren haben solche gesetze
schreiben die spaltung der gesellschaft
voran herr scholz das müssen doch auch
sie inzwischen mal merken wir haben seit
über zwei jahren mit den auswirkungen
der pandemie zu kämpfen viele menschen
sind ausgelaugt die bundesregierung hat
immer noch keinen plan herr lauterbach
früchte tja das im herbst die
infektionszahlen wieder nach oben gehen
könnten sind wir darauf eigentlich
vorbereitet gibt es inzwischen zum
beispiel genug personal in den
krankenhäusern
ich werde ihnen sagen nein woher soll es
auch kommen sie haben nichts aber auch
gar nichts an den schlechten
arbeitsbedingungen für die pflegerinnen
und pfleger verbessert nicht mal den
pflege bonus haben alle bekommen aber
von nichts kommt nun mal nichts herr
lauterbach
viele menschen viele menschen blicken
mit großer sorge in die zukunft so
unsicher wie jetzt war das leben
hierzulande lange nicht mehr zwei
flugstunden von uns entfernt doch putins
krieg in der ukraine seit über drei
monaten sterben dort tag für tag
menschen tausende sind auf der flucht
die weitere entwicklung und auch die
auswirkungen sind vollkommen ungewiss
außerdem geht der klimawandel weitgehend
ungebremst voran auch erbe fördert die
soziale spaltung hierzulande und in der
welt fakt ist diese bundesregierung gibt
keine sozialen antworten auf die krisen
unserer zeit und das geht so nicht
kollegen
beginnen wir mit den schlagenden
lebenshaltungskosten hier braucht es
dringend eine wirksame staatliche
preisaufsicht für lebensmittel energie
damit schluss ist mit den mondpreisen es
braucht direktzahlungen die die realen
preissteigerungen auf wirklich abfedern
es braucht einen schutzschirm für
betroffene unternehmen und beschäftigte
gerade auch im hinblick auf das
bevorstehende öl embargo das die lage
deutlich verschärfen wird es braucht
eine echte offensive zur schaffung von
bezahlbarem wohnraum besonders in
ballungsgebieten den wohnraum darf kein
luxus sein es ist ein menschenrecht und
ja und ja wir brauchen entschlossene
maßnahmen im kampf gegen den klimawandel
aber dafür muss man auch bereit sein in
klimaschutz zu investieren in die
notwendige transformation vor allem in
die dekarbonisierung der wirtschaft in
erneuerbare energien all das muss aber
auch einher gehen mit klaren
perspektiven und einer sicherung von
arbeitsplätzen klimaschutz der kann nur
gelingen wenn er sozial gerecht ist das
die wahrheit aber
was macht stattdessen die bundes für
keine der aufgezeigten probleme sind im
haushalt auch nur ansatzweise genügend
mittel eingestellt im bereich sozialen
wohnungsbau wissen sie ja nicht mal wie
es hier die einstellen müssten um ihre
zahl von 100.000 sozialwohnungen pro
jahr zu erreichen das hat eine anfrage
meiner kollegin karin meyer aufgedeckte
so wirklich ein skandal zu den
explodierenden energiekosten
gibt es flüchtige entlastungs päckchen
die realen mehrkosten werden nicht mal
im ansatz ausgeglichen einmalig bis zu
300 euro das lächerlich studierende
rentner und rentner wie gesagt gehen
komplett leer aus das einfach unerhört
hubertus heil der will jetzt mit einem
sozial gestaffelten klima geld
nachbessern schön aber davon müssen sie
halt erstmal ihr eigenes kabinett
überzeugen da kommt ja jetzt schon eine
menge gegenwind und selbst wenn es
kommen sollte dann frühestens anfang
nächsten jahres in welcher höhe keiner
weiß wirklich absurd kolleginnen
kollegen
bei all dem
macht man sich doch zu recht für wen
machen sie eigentlich politik weil damen
und herren von der anbieter für die 38
prozent der menschen in unserem land die
kaum noch über die runden kommen sicher
nicht aber
es gibt durchaus leute die von ihrer
politik profitieren die aktionäre von
energiekonzernen zum beispiel die freuen
sich gerade über rekordgewinne der
ölmulti shell hat gerade verkündet dass
seine gewinne um 43 prozent gestiegen
sind man könnte diese krassen krisen
gewinne steuerlich abschöpfen das macht
italien zum beispiel wir haben das als
linke hier mehrfach eingebracht mit
diesen steuerlichen mehreinnahmen könnte
man die menschen entlasten was hat
scheint für sie unvorstellbar ich bin so
unglaublich
ja
wir wissen sie alle alle superreichen
hält deutschland können sich darauf
verlassen dass diese bundesregierung
unter ihnen unter keinen umständen an
das prall gefüllte bankkonto gehen und
zwar egal wie groß die not ist denn wo
ist die vermögenssteuer liebe spd liebe
grünen im wahlkampf waren sie doch mal
voll dafür da haben sie doch noch
verstanden dass zum beispiel der lidl
chef schwarz dessen vermögen in einem
jahr um sage und schreibe 16 milliarden
euro gestiegen ist dass der
selbstverständlich einen angemessenen
anteil dafür das gemeinwohl zurück
führen müsste aber seit sie in der
regierung sind kein wort mehr von einer
vermögenssteuer und
bei wem
knallen diese woche die sektkorken so
richtig genau bei den aktionären der
rüstungskonzern weil sie an diesem
freitag allen ernstes unser grundgesetz
ändern wollen um 100 milliarden schweres
auf rüstungsprogramm hineinzuschreiben
seit der bloßen ankündigung dieses auf
rüstungsprogramms ist der aktienkurs von
rheinmetall bereits um 100 prozent
gestiegen merken dass 100 milliarden
euro für rüstung und das obwohl der beta
bereits heute bei 50 milliarden euro pro
jahr liegt er es jahr für jahr gestiegen
ist einfach falsch tochter abgesicherte
wurde jahr für jahr ist er angestiegen
trotzdem behaupten sie die 100
milliarden wären notwendig um die
bundeswehr fit zu machen um es mal klar
zu sagen natürlich muss die bundeswehr
in der lage sein ihren grund
gesetzlichen auftrag die
landesverteidigung zu erfüllen aber dass
sie das heute nicht kann das liegt nicht
an zu wenig geld auch der
bundesrechnungshof sagt man müsse klären
ob nicht andere gründe ursächlich sind
für die mangelnde einsatzbereitschaft
zum beispiel strukturelle defizite bei
der organisation der bundeswehr wir
wissen doch das ist ein eklatantes
missmanagement gibt und das ist auch der
grund für die probleme nicht so wenig
geld dass die wahl um
es ganz klar zu
dieses sondervermögen ist gegenüber den
millionen menschen unserem land die
existenzielle sorgen und nöte haben
einfach eine unverschämtheit ich kann
das nicht glauben aber
auch leben politisch ist es verheerend
eine aufrüstung spirale macht die welt
nicht friedlicher das wissen wir doch
das gegenteil ist der fall man dass die
union das die fdp mit so einer politik
keine probleme haben das keine
überraschung aber kolleginnen und
kollegen von der spd sie kommen aus der
tradition von willy brandt kolleginnen
und kollegen von den grünen sie kommen
doch aus der friedensbewegung
100 milliarden euro für ausrüstung ins
grundgesetz schreiben das doch irrsinn
machen sie da doch nicht mit
der prinz
das möchte ich auch einmal sagen gegen
waffenlieferungen in kriegsgebiete zu
sein insbesondere gegen schwere
waffenlieferung das hat nichts mit
pazifismus zu tun wir haben das hier vor
kurzem einmal dargestellt hat es hat
etwas mit vernunft zu tun russland ist
die größte atommacht der welt in
militärischen mitteln ist dieser krieg
nicht zu gewinnen es braucht
deeskalation es braucht diplomatie es
braucht wirksamer sanktionen gegen die
russische führung gegen die mächtige
oligarchen damit möglichst schnell der
krieg endet dafür die mitte links noch
nicht ausgeschöpft und das wissen sie
auch
sie haben versprochen
unter ihnen ja ich weiß dass wir umgehen
ist aber die wahrheit sie haben
versprochen unter ihnen als
finanzminister wird es keine schulden
geben keine neuen schulden geben was sie
hier aber irreführend als sondervermögen
bezeichnen ist in wirklichkeit nichts
anderes ist sind neue schulden kräftig
geht dass für alles andere soll aber ab
2023 die schuldenbremse wieder gelten
diese schuldenbremse wegen der seit
jahren während der seit jahren immer
wieder heißt es sei kein geld da die
schuldenbremse wegen der städte und
gemeinden immer öfter schwierigkeiten
haben öffentliche schwimmbäder
bibliotheken jugendclubs oder sogar
frauen heute offen zu halten die
schuldenbremse wegen des verheerenden
einem investitionsstopp gibt bei straßen
brücken und dem schienennetz von in
schnellem internet will ich gar nicht
anfangen herr lindner sagt wir müssen an
unsere kinder und enkel denken deshalb
bräuchte es die schuldenbremse aber
das ist volkswirtschaftlich leider
völliger und denn selbst denn selbst die
sprichwörtliche schwäbische hausfrau die
angela merkel damals als kronzeugen für
die einführung der schuldenbremse bemüht
hat als sinnbild für eine ordentlich
wirtschaftende person selbst die
schwäbische hausfrau würde einen kredit
aufnehmen um ihr kaputtes dach zu
sanieren statt es einfach rein regnen zu
lassen insbesondere in den zins zeit
vergehen müssen die kinder und enkel
denken und deshalb dürfen wir ihn doch
kein verfallenes haus hinterlassen das
ist doch die wahrheit kolleginnen und
kollegen wir brauchen investitionen für
unsere zukunft zum beispiel für den
konsequenten ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien und der arbeit meinten sie
eigentlich dass mit progressiver politik
wenn sie für aufrüstung wenn zur
aufrüstung 100 milliarden bereitgestellt
werden die investitionen in erneuerbare
energien aber unter dem vorbehalt der
schuldenbremse stehen oder wenn sie ihre
umweltziele einfach aufgeben und sich
für fracking gas terminals einsetzen
oder zulassen dass das weltnaturerbe
wattenmeer durch gasbohrung gefährdet
wird wie erklären sie das eigentlich
ihren wählerinnen ist mir ein rätsel
ich denke ich denke es ist klar geworden
warum wir diesen haushalt nicht
zustimmen können er ist nicht sozial und
zutiefst ungerecht und dazu können wir
als linke niemals jahr hin
amira mohammed ali von den linken
kritisiert die zunehmende soziale
spaltung im lande das entlastungspaket
bringe den rentnern nichts auf die
nächste corona welle sei das land nicht
vorbereitet gegen den klimawandel werde
zu wenig getan und 100 milliarden für
die bundeswehr versucht eine
unverschämtheit es werde nur zu einer
aufrüstung spirale führen nächster
redner ist nun christian dürr der
fraktionsvorsitzende
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
kollegen das jahr
2022 also der staat diese
regierungskoalition steht unter
vorzeichen die wir uns vor fast genau
einem halben jahr während der
koalitionsverhandlungen nicht hätten
vorstellen können nicht nur spüren wir
die wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
nachwirkungen des höhepunktes der korona
pandemie das alles rückt ja in den
hintergrund angesichts des
angriffskrieges russlands in der ukraine
und die schrecklichen bilder die wir von
dort täglich sehen die zerstörung und
das leid das wir dort sehen sind
schrecklich und jegliche unterstützung
die wir leisten ist richtig und
notwendig ich möchte daher an dieser
stelle noch einmal deutlich sagen egal
was wir tun wir dürfen uns an die bilder
aus der ukraine nicht gewöhnen meine
damen und herren wir dürfen uns da diese
bilder nicht gewinnen
und wir reagieren indem wir eng an der
seite der ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
stehen die auch für die europäische
freiheit kämpfen wir unterstützen
finanziell ganz konkret den ukrainischen
staat damit erweitern von funktioniert
ganz konkret in diesem bundeshaushalt
abgestimmt mit den g 7 stellen wir eine
milliarde zusätzlich deutsche steuergeld
zur verfügung um die funktionsfähigkeit
des ukrainischen staates aufrecht zu
halten auch das ist ein wichtiges signal
dieser haushaltsberatungen über
politische
und
wir schaffen etwas weiteres mit diesem
bundeshaushalt es hat schon viele war
stellen auch gesprochen worden beim
generalbundesanwalt der
bundesjustizminister beim
generalbundesanwalt schaffen wir stellen
für die verfolgung von kriegsverbrechen
meinen damen und herren diese
kriegsverbrechen in der ukraine dürfen
nicht ungesühnt bleiben wir werden die
täter verfolgen meine damen und herren
auch von deutschen und strafverfolgungen
wenn wir also über diesen bundeshaushalt
sprechen in diesem jahr sprechen wir
über veränderte gegebenheiten über eine
geopolitisch andere welt als noch vor
zwei monaten
hier steht ja insbesondere das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr im
fokus der bundeskanzler hat das hier
vorgeschlagen am 27 februar ich bin dem
bundesfinanzminister ausdrücklich
dankbar für seine verhandlungsführung
ich bin ihm dankbar dass er die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion davon
abgehalten hat die einen absurden
abzählreim am freitag durchzuführen
meine damen und herren wir schaffen es
mit diesem sondervermögen die bundeswehr
endlich so auszustatten wie sie
ausgestattet werden muss die eine
moderne armee ausgestattet werden muss
das wurde in den vergangenen zwei
jahrzehnten sträflich vernachlässigt und
es dient nicht nur unserer eigenen
sicherheit
sondern das sind wir endlich auch den
soldatinnen und soldaten der bundeswehr
schuldig meine damen und herren ihm das
auch klar zu sagen
ein zweiter punkt der mir in dem
zusammenhang mit dem sondervermögen
wichtig ist wir weichen nicht von der
schuldenbremse ab wir schleifen nicht
die schuldenbremse im grundgesetz
sondern wir werden am freitag mit zwei
drittel mehrheit dieses sondervermögen
beschließen was speziell der bundeswehr
zur verfügung steht und vor allen dingen
herr kollege merz wer erhöhen nicht die
steuern ich war heute morgen
sicher dass der oppositionsführer viele
fragen erneut stellen wird oder eigene
konzepte vorzulegen aber an einer stelle
haben sie mich belangt überrascht damit
war nicht zu rechnen
der spd vorzuwerfen
sie hätte den soli abschaffen müssen
damit sie jetzt als cdu csu den
vorschlag machen können den soli fahren
menschen wieder ernsthaft rhein zu führt
wie absurd ist das denn meine damen und
herren das ist die neue finanzpolitische
kompetenz der cdu csu und deutschland
liebe kollegen polit absurd was beinahe
tobacco schloss die fed ist mir nicht
träumen lassen ich hätte es mir nicht
träumen lassen
diese
bundesregierung herr merz diese
koalition ist mit einer doppelten
hypothek der 16-jährigen und jüngst
geführten bundesregierung gestartet
erstens eine vernachlässigte bundeswehr
sprach gerade darüber und andererseits
eine sehr gefährliche abhängigkeit
von russland bei der energie deshalb ist
das im koalitionsvertrag verankerte
thema planungs beschleunigung der wollen
planungs beschleunigung in deutschland
so voran bringen dass wir die planungs
und genehmigungszeiten halbiert
dringlicher denn je hier sind wir in der
letzten sitzungswoche einen ersten
schritt gegangen mit dem ausbau von lng
terminals einen ersten wichtigen schritt
und ich schlage vor dass wir genau daran
anknüpfen sollten wenn wir darüber reden
dass die wirtschaft in den nächsten
jahren massive investitionen tätigen
muss dann darf das ja nicht jahrzehnte
dauern dann brauchen wir schnelle
verfahren in allen bereichen der
wirtschaft der industrie in deutschland
unterbauch bei die infrastrukturvorhaben
des staates meine damen denn das was wir
hier vorgeschlagen haben das was wir
durch den deutschen bundestag gebracht
haben bei den lng terminals mit der mit
dem ziel der energieunabhängigkeit ist
ja geradezu eine blaupause für weitere
projekte meine damen und herren um die
transformation der wirtschaft nach vorne
zu bringen kaum ein land der welt ich
will dass zum thema klimaschutz an der
stelle sagen kaum ein land der welt hat
in den letzten jahrzehnten so viel geld
klimaschutz ausgegeben aber so wenig für
klimaschutz erreicht meine damen und
herren das müssen wir umdrehen wir
brauchen auch planungs beschleunigung
damit wir energie unabhängig werden und
endlich den klimaschutz entsprechenden
deutschland voranbringen und die
transformation unserer volkswirtschaft
liebe kollegen tun
und
diese
diese ampel koalition ist angetreten um
das leben der menschen in deutschland zu
verbessern das mag erst pathetisch
klingen aber das ist jetzt sehr konkret
herr merz denn das was wir jetzt sehen
dass die letzten wochen und monate für
viele menschen sehr sehr hart gewesen
sind und leider wahrscheinlich nicht
einfacher werden ich denke an die
millionen familien mit kleinen ankommen
die die gestiegenen preise jetzt sehr
deutlich spüren und dennoch alles dafür
tun damit ihre kinder alles bekommen was
sie brauchen ich denke an die
gastronomen in unserem land die erst
unter der pandemie und jetzt unter einem
enormen personallage bleiben ich denke
an die vielen handwerksbetriebe die
weiteren junge menschen ausbilden und
die jeden tag auf die lieferwagen und
auf ihre transporter angewiesen sind ich
finde es daher richtig dass wir es
geschafft haben in den letzten wochen so
viele entlastung auf den weg zu bringen
um all diese menschen zu erreichen wir
haben den kinderbonus erhöht die
heizkostenpauschale erhöht die
einmalzahlung in höhe von 100 euro für
transferempfänger die energie pauschale
in höhe von 300 euro für alle
erwerbstätigen die einführung des 99
euro tickets wurde gesagt und die
senkung der steuern auf benzin und
diesel die höhen in der einkommensteuer
dauerhaft und rückwirkend zum ersten
januar den grundfreibetrag der
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag und die
pendlerpauschale
meine damen und herren wir werden für
die unternehmen in deutschland das was
ich als damals noch haushalts und
finanzpolitiker in der opposition immer
gefordert habe nämlich den steuerlichen
verlust rückt dauerhaft auszuweiten wer
in der vergangenheit als unternehmer in
deutschland
solidarisch mit dem steuer start war
weil er oder sie gewinne gezeigt hat mit
dem muss jetzt auch der steuerstaat in
schwierigen zeiten solidarisch sein dass
diese regierungskoalition
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und wir entlasten gezielt und reagieren
angemessen auf die aktuelle
wirtschaftliche lage und die hohe
belastung der menschen in diesem land
heute tritt die senkung der
energiesteuern kraft um die pendlerinnen
und pendler zu entlassen und ich habe ja
die ersten meldungen dazu gesehen im
ersten schritt obgleich natürlich noch
alter alter des benziners diese
sozusagen in den tank ist aufgrund der
damals höheren steuersätze trotzdem
sinken glücklicherweise heute morgen die
preise an den tankstellen wir müssen die
menschen im ländlichen raum weiter im
blick behalten
60 prozent der menschen in deutschland
wo nicht in urbanen zentren sondern sie
wohnen im ländlichen raum das sind viele
pendlerinnen und pendler das sind viele
familien und diese regierungskoalition
erhält genau diese menschen im blick auf
das will ich an der stelle deutlich
bleiben
und wir schaffen mit diesem
bundeshaushalt etwas weiteres über
bildung ist für meine begriffe noch zu
wenig gesprochen und wurden heute morgen
diese bundesregierung bringt eine große
bafög reform auf den weg und sie
finanziert sie auch und ich will eines
in aller klarheit sagen weil das in den
letzten jahren ja ich muss das sagen
herr merz und die letzte
bundesbildungsministerin die über nicht
kann philosophiert hat kam ja von der
cdu ich will das in aller klarheit sagen
wir müssen an einer stelle in
deutschland einer gerechtigkeitsfrage
den hebel umlegen die frage wie man im
leben voran kommt darf nicht vom
elternhaus abhängig sein sonst muss man
allerdings sagen wie man sich anstrengt
in denen jeder muss diese chance haben
das tun wir mit dieser reform
ich will deshalb insgesamt diesen
haushalt in ein verhältnis setzen wir
erhöhen die investitionen um 50
milliarden euro das sind ist zum jahr
350 milliarden euro investitionen des
bundes mehr als jemals zuvor
wir werden die ausgaben für den
bundeshaushalt
2022 um 77 milliarden aus euro
reduzieren und gleichzeitig machen wir
100 milliarden euro weniger schulden als
die große koalition
2021 wir setzen die richtigen
prioritäten und der bundeshaushalt
2022 ist der auftakt für den
bundeshaushalt des kommenden jahres
gehen wir hier in wenigen wochen bereits
diskutieren werden das ist der
unterschied zur unionsgeführten
vorgängerregierung und ich will das
sagen herr merz wer immer mehr fordert
um gleichzeitig zu hoher ausgaben
kritisiert der passt nach meiner
rechnung an der stelle nicht zusammen
wenn es nach ihren vorschlägen und jetzt
will ich auf ihre arbeit während der
letzten wochen als opposition zu
sprechen kommen wenn es nach ihren
vorschlägen geht würden wir in diesem
jahr als koalition 60 milliarden euro
mehr schulden machen das ist doch die
wahrheit herr merz ich habe mir ihre
anträge im haushaltsausschuss sehr genau
angeschaut sie wollen 60 milliarden aus
dem energie und klimafonds einsätzen für
das was sie vorhaben also sie nutzen
eine rücklage von der sie selbst sagen
sie sei verfassungswidrig
das passt nicht ich frage sie welches
verfassungsorgan wollen sie hinter die
fichte führt das
bundesverfassungsgericht oder den
deutschen bundestag herr kollege merz
das müssen sie beantworten
und frage ich sie wo ist ihr plan zur
rückkehr zur schuldenbremse wo ist
eigentlich der plan der union um zur
schuldenbremse im kommenden jahr
zurückzukehren ich habe schon mal gesagt
und wiederhole es an dieser stelle gerne
die schuldenbremse ist bei christian
lindner und olaf scholz in besseren
händen als bei friedrich merz und
alexandra droben um das in aller
klarheit zu sagen
kollegen und
ich habe in der letzten beiträge öfter
gesagt dass eine oppositionsarbeit auch
so verstehen muss dass man service
opposition ist in dem man intelligente
vorschläge macht und auch alternativen
zur regierungsarbeit vorschlägt gerade
weil die öffentlichkeit aus meiner sicht
ein anrecht darauf hat herr kollege mehr
hat diese 60 milliarden die schlank weg
in ihren haushalts vorschlägen stehen
fehlen jetzt stehen zwar drin aber die
fehlen in der sache die fehlen in der
sache weil sie selbst sagen das sei ja
verfassungswidriges geld stichwort
service opposition das was wir in den
letzten wochen bei den
haushaltsberatungen der cdu/csu erlebt
haben das ist keine service opposition
das ist eine einzige servicewüste
gewesen meine damen und herren da ist
nichts bei rum gekommen
haushaltspolitisch gar nichts von dem
was sie da vorgelegt haben und deswegen
will ich zum schluss ein wichtiges thema
ansprechen was sie auch angedeutet haben
vorher idol ein kollege der cdu csu
fraktion auch gestern bei der debatte
zur finanzpolitik um den einzelplan des
bundesfinanzministers nämlich die frage
der altersversorgung in deutschland
diese bundesregierung wird den
nachholfaktor in der rente wieder
einführen wir priorisieren im haushalt
so dass wir entsprechendes auch schaffen
in zukunft in richtung kapital der
kapitaldeckung bei der altersvorsorge zu
gehen und ich will ihnen das in aller
klarheit sagen ich bin da schon sehr
sehr verwundert herr merz sie sagen nach
16 jahren verantwortung bei der rente
sei es irgendwie gescheitert sie haben
die bundeskanzlerin gestellt mit verlaub
nein das ist nicht ich habe hier
gesessen für irland nicht an der spd
alles gescheitert
dies vor allem die union gewesen die bis
heute keinen retten konzept vorlegen
kann bis heute haben die keinen
vorschlag zu machen wie es besser geht
und deswegen
will ich einen sehr konkreten
kürzungsvorschlag den sie vorgelegt
haben als fraktion aufgreifen sie kürzen
bei der beruflichen integration für
zuwanderer mag wie ein kleiner artikel
erst mal klingen ich glaube das ist ein
verräterischer vorschlag walter
innerhalb weit eine andere halten da
steckt eine andere halten und dabei
einen viel größeren thema ich will in
diese klare frage stellen herbergs
wollen sie mit dem historischen fehler
der eigenen partei aufräumen und
deutschland endlich zu einem modernen
ein wohnungsbrand nacht oder wünschen
dass sie in wirtschaftlichen interesse
unseres landes es ist im westen
nationalen interesse der bundesrepublik
deutschland dass wir endlich ein
modernes einwanderungsland werden denn
nur so werden die die fachkräfte bekommt
nur so werden die renten der zukunft
absichern auf diese zentrale
zukunftsfrage die diese
regierungsfraktion sich in den
koalitionsvertrag geschrieben hat haben
sie nicht eine einzige antwort heute
geliefert nicht in der vergangenheit
hier handeln ich dagegen
auch der fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp
sieht heftig die union und verteidigt
natürlich den haushalt vor allem das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr er
betonte die übrigens gestern auch
finanzminister lindner dass ab nächstem
jahr wieder die schuldenbremse gelten
soll den vorschlag der union den soli
wieder einzuführen hält dürfe absurd es
folgt thorsten frei der parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der unions-fraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich finde es schon eine bemerkenswerte
strategie wenn ich die vertreter der
koalitionsfraktionen hier höre und sie
den überwiegenden teil ihrer rede zeit
darauf verwenden die koalition die
opposition zu beschimpfen das ist
sicherlich keine zukunftsträchtige
strategie wenn es darum geht die
herausforderungen der zukunft zu lösen
zu bewältigen und in der tat es sind
wichtige zeiten in denen wir stehen es
gibt ereignisse die zeilen die zeit in
ein davor und ineinander und der
verbrecherischen angriffskrieg russlands
auf die ukraine ist ein solches ereignis
und deswegen hat der herr bundeskanzler
heute hier auch sehr viel über die
zeitenwende der großen staaten
gesprochen es gibt aber zeitgleich auch
eine zeitenwende der kleinen leute und
die beginnt nicht mit einer
kriegserklärung sondern die kommt
schleichend und lautlos daher wie ist
unerbittlich und sie ist enttäuschend
für viele menschen und auch
existenzbedrohlich und diese zeitenwende
macht vor allen dingen rentner arbeiter
und sparer zu den großen verlierern
dieser zeit und diese zeitenwende heißt
inflation und sie
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
antworten darauf nur mit dem kurieren
von symptomen nicht indem sie die
ursachen der inflation der
geldentwertung bekämpfen und sie herr
bundeskanzler haben heute morgen gelobt
wie die rentensteigerung ausfallen wird
ja wir hatten im letzten jahr eine
geldentwertung von 3,1 prozent in diesem
jahr von 7,9 prozent das sind mehr als
zwei prozent als die rentensteigerung
die wir dieses jahr bekommen werden das
heißt nicht mehr für die menschen
sondern weniger in den geldbeuteln das
ist die wahrheit und darauf sollten sie
eine antwort finden in dieser situation
in dieser situation die gebe ich ihnen
gerne in dieser situation sind vor allen
dingen diejenigen getroffen die den
ratschlag vieler politiker in den
vergangenen jahren beherzigt haben
nämlich fürs alter vorzusorgen
aber in dieser situation schmilzt die
altersvorsorge der menschen hier in
deutschland wie eis in der sonne das ist
das ergebnis ihrer politik und ich will
an dieser stelle ich will an dieser
stelle meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren auch von den grünen ich will an
dieser stelle einmal den früheren
bundesfinanzminister
zitieren der hat nämlich im juni letzten
jahres also vor ziemlich genau einem
jahr folgenden satz gesagt zitat ich
will allen die sorge nehmen dass wir mit
der inflation ein allzu großes problem
bekommen die inflation wird viel
geringer und ganz normal ausfallen als
viele befürchten das hat der damalige
bundesfinanzminister vor einem jahr
gesagt und ich will ihnen nicht
vorwerfen dass sie anders als andere die
herr aufkommenden probleme nicht erkannt
haben dass sie sie weg geschrieben
hatten aber was ihnen vorzuwerfen ist
ist dass sie bis heute es nicht als
zentrale herausforderungen ihrer
kanzlerschaft begriffen haben etwas
dagegen zu tun dass das geld der
menschen mehr und mehr entwertet wird
dass die herausforderungen wenn sie es
täten dann würden sie eine andere
fiskalpolitik machen dann würden sie
insbesondere auf europäischer ebene nach
anderen regeln rufen sie tun es
allerdings nicht und deswegen sage ich
ihnen eines der kampf gegen die
geldentwertung das ist sozialer
verantwortung der kampf gegen die
geldentwertung das ist
leistungsgerechtigkeit und deswegen
fordern wir sie auf endlich dieses thema
auch anzugehen und zwar nicht
indem man an den symptomen herum dorf
dort sondern indem man die ursachen
bekämpft und ich will vor diesem
hintergrund noch ein letztes zitat heute
ansprechen es stammt vom früheren
oppositionspolitiker und heutigen
finanzminister christian lindner er hat
damals über die inflation die er früher
als andere erkannt und den damaligen
bundesfinanzminister folgendes gesagt
zitat der staat attackiert lindner
scholz den er mit einem karnevalsprinzen
vergleicht ist einer der größten wenn
nicht der größte treiber von inflation
als finanzminister war olaf scholz mit
kamelle um sich und weiter die
öffentlichen finanzen solide zu halten
ist der wesentliche baustein der
inflationsbekämpfung wenn die ezb das
schlepptau der fiskalpolitik stark
verschuldeter staaten geraten würde dann
hätte sie kaum eine möglichkeit die
inflation zu bekämpfen
zitat ende und statt neuer schulden
müsste deutschland so lindner dem zitat
tilgungs toro anwerfen also unsolide
staatsfinanzen schmettert lindner scholz
entgegen gefährden die preisstabilität
ich finde besser kann man es nicht
zusammenfassen und umso mehr fragt man
sich ob das wirklich der mann ist der
sechs monate später einen
verfassungswidrigen
nachtragshaushalt mit 60 milliarden
neuen schulden vorlegt die ganz sicher
auch vor dem bundesverfassungsgericht
scheitern werden ob das der gleich
jemand ist der zwölf monate später mit
240 milliarden euro nettoneuverschuldung
die höchste neuverschuldung in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland zu verantworten hat meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren ich will
ihnen sagen es gibt etwas das schmilzt
noch schneller als das vermögen der
deutschen
und das ist die glaubwürdigkeit der fdp
sie schmilzt das eis in der sonne
meine sehr verehrten damen und
und vor diesem hintergrund stellt sich
wirklich die frage
wir haben ein bundeskanzler der regiert
das problem und tut auch jetzt so als
gäbe es nicht wir haben ein
bundesfinanzminister der erkenntnis
problem handelt aber gegensätzlich und
damit wird eines deutlich es ist es
muster ihrer koalition diese koalition
wird zusammengehalten durch schulden
schulden und noch mehr schulden es ist
der kitt dieser koalition damit wird
alles zugeschüttet aber was vielleicht
so grebe blenden uns an dieser stelle
aus aus aus einer recht lebhaften
debatte und schalten noch einmal ganz
kurz zu meiner kollegin andrea maurer
andrea haben wir da gerade einen
typischen olaf scholz erlebt oder hat er
es geschafft endlich mal verständlich
vielsagend und klar zu kommunizieren
er hat ja immerhin auch die lieferung
neuer schwerer waffen zugesagt
ja also ich würde sagen dass war ein
ungewöhnlicher scholz heute hier im
parlament hat tatsächlich klare ansagen
gemacht neue waffen versprochen einen
ordnungsrahmen für die ukraine und ein
luftabwehrsystem mit diesem abwehrsystem
könne eine ganze ukrainische großstadt
vor russischen angriffen geschützt
werden so scholz also es war
überraschend in der ansage nicht so
überraschend war waren die attacken die
der oppositionsführer friedrich merz
gefahren hat er hat ihm ja das zaudern
vorgeworfen und dass er das ansehen
deutschlands international beschädigt
aber dann kam eben scholz und er hat
sich von seinem manuskript gelöst hat
direkt auf den oppositionsführer
reagiert hat ihn peinlich genannt seine
vorschläge merkwürdig und das war dann
tatsächlich doch eine sehr lebhafte
debatte die attacken die märz geplant
hatte die kamen heute hier also deutlich
gegen ihn zurück auch aus dem kreis der
koalitionspartner die fdp hat sofort
einen hashtag auf twitter in die welt
gesetzt märz soli der märz hat ja einen
solidaritätszuschlag gefordert um das
sondervermögen der bundeswehr zu
finanzieren und da wurde doch deutlich
auch noch einmal auf die
verantwortung der union verwiesen in den
letzten 16 jahren hier was was die
bundeswehr betrifft und dass
steuererhöhungen tatsächlich dann doch
fehl am platz waren also eine sehr
lebhafte debatte hier heute im parlament
ja vielen dank andrea und die
diskussionen werden sicherlich weiter
gehen ich bedanke mich für ihr interesse
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit der
sendung soko wismar ich wünsche ihnen
noch einen schönen tag und sage tschüss
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]